Ja, heute mal 10 Minuten früher als sonst.
Oh, wartet mal kurz.
Wartet mal kurz.
Sonst.
Irgendwas.
Stimmt.
Oh, wartet mal kurz.
Mit dem Headset nicht.
Wartet mal.
Oh, ich wusste es.
Oh, wartet mal kurz.
So.
Ja, jetzt ist es besser.
Lass mich mal kurz entwirren.
So.
Ja, jetzt ist es besser.
Exzellent.
Ist das.
Oder auch nicht.
So, ich muss mal kurz muten.
So, jetzt besser.
So.
Moin.
Twitch sagt, ich habe null Zuschauer.
Chat, ihr zählt nicht.
Was ist da los?
Nicht dick genug.
Kann Twitch die User nicht zählen.
Bei dir steht 42, bei mir steht null.
A Refreshen.
Guck, vielleicht geht es dann.
Jetzt steht bei mir 30.
Exzellent.
Ja, jetzt scheint es zu funktionieren.
Nögt.
Ich muss euch mal das wirklich painstampige jetzt zeigen.
Ich habe ja gestern ein bisschen umgebaut bei mir.
Netzwerk habe ich in den Keller gelegt vom ersten Stock aus.
Ich sage euch, es war schwieriger, schwieriger als ich mir das vorgestellt habe.
Ich habe das ja schon im Stream angekündigt, dass ich das jetzt machen will.
Also, ich habe hier hinten, ich versuche das euch nochmal kurz für die letzten Stream nicht dabei waren zu erklären.
Ich habe hier hinten, ich versuche das euch nochmal kurz für die letzten Stream nicht dabei waren zu erklären.
Was ich versucht habe.
Also, das hier ist das Video von dem Surferraum, wo es hier so unordentlich ist.
Aber das ist eigentlich ganz gut.
Hier hinten habe ich einen Kabelkanal.
Leider ist er in diesem Video komplett zugedeckt.
Man sieht ihn nicht.
Also, hier hinten ist ein Kabelkanal.
Da kommen Kabel raus aus dem Erdgeschoss und aus dem Keller.
Die Sache ist nur die, das Kabel, was in den Keller ging, muss ich euch das zweite Video zeigen.
Also, ich habe hier.
Hier sieht man es.
Hier sieht man es wunderbar.
Ich habe nur ein Kabel, was in den Keller geht von diesem Raum.
Das ist ein K788-Adern-Dings-Patch-Kabel.
So ein ganz, ganz normales grünes Ding.
Gut, die Farbe ist jetzt egal.
So, also ich habe hier ein Kabel durchliegen.
Aber Massive Brained haben die Typen, die das gebaut haben, sich gedacht, weil ich habe denen gesagt, hey, ich will meinen Telekomanschluss, ich will den Telefonanschluss, will ich hier haben.
Ich will nicht jedes Mal hier.
Ich will nicht jedes Mal in den Keller, falls ich mal irgendwie Router neu starten muss oder sonst irgendwas.
Damals habe ich noch nicht an Wireless-Steckdosen gedacht.
Also, die haben gedacht, also ich habe denen gesagt, ich brauche ein Netzwerkkabel und ich will die, also ich brauche mindestens ein Kabel, Keller, Serverraum und ich will die Netzwerkdose, die Telefondose will ich hier oben haben, nicht im Keller.
Also, was haben die gemacht?
Die haben das wörtlich genommen, was ich ihnen gesagt habe.
Die haben ein Netzwerkkabel gelegt.
Netzwerkkabel.
Also, sieht ja von innen so aus.
So sieht das ja von innen aus.
Du hast da halt 8 Adern drin.
Und der ziemlich genauso, so sieht das auch aus hier.
Ich habe auch extra shielded und sonst was.
Du hast da 8 Adern drin und jetzt haben sie Big Braintime gemacht.
Sie haben, richtig, richtig weird champ.
Sie haben einfach 2 Adernpaare von diesen 8 genommen für die Telefonanlage.
Telefondose.
Das Problem ist nur, Chat, wer ist so schlau, wer weiß, wie viele Adern braucht man für Gigabit?
Wie viele Adern braucht man für Gigabit?
8!
Genau!
Richtiger Five-Hat-Moment.
Also, sie haben im Endeffekt das gemacht, was ich wollte.
Netzwerkkabel und Telefonsteckdose angeschlossen.
Nur, dass sie es so gemacht haben, dass ich nichts davon verwenden kann.
So.
Also, was habe ich gemacht?
Ich bin hier hin, habe das aufgemacht.
Habe die Telefondose rausgebaut, habe das Kabel abgeschnitten, bin in den Keller runter, habe das dort abgeschnitten von dem Gegenstück von der Telekom.
Ich brauche das Ding ja nicht, ich bin ja komplett über Unity Media und VoIP.
Ich habe ja keinerlei Telekom-Zeug bei mir im Einsatz.
So, dann hatte ich ein Kabel mit 8 Adern drin.
Und der Mist liegt auch nicht im Leerrohr.
Ne, aber das ist mit meine Schuld, weil ich nicht explizit gesagt habe, macht mal Rohre.
Auf der anderen Seite, ja, ja gut.
Auf der anderen Seite hätte man auch sagen können, ey, wir machen das auch so, aber egal.
Pater, oh herrlich, danke schön, 12 Monate Hyper-Subscription.
Ja, Leerrohr ist nicht so angesagt.
Hyper-Subscription hier, ich finde den Sound nicht.
Komm mal, Gento installieren.
Ne, habe ich öfters zugeguckt und das will ich nicht selbst machen.
Ich hatte einen Kollegen auf der Arbeit, der war damals der Meinung, er muss Gento installieren.
Und er hat gefühlt zwei Tage gebraucht, bis es lief, dass sein Netzwerktreiber in der VM funktioniert hat.
Eigentlich ist das eine witzige Idee, das könnte man echt mal machen.
Das könnte man echt mal machen.
So, also, was ich jetzt gemacht habe ist, unten abgeschnippelt.
So, und dann habe ich den Rat vom Chat befolgt und habe mir einen Keystone AJ45 Stecker gekauft.
Also ein Vierer-Pack, solche Dinger.
Und die habe ich dann oben und unten drauf gemacht.
Und dann ist mir aufgefallen, ich habe ja sogar, also richtig, richtig massive Brain-Chat.
So sieht das aus, genau.
So sieht das aus.
Du fädelst hier, du fädelst hier die einzelnen Adern ein.
Dann steckst du das quasi kopfüber da rein und machst den Stecker zu.
Und dann, hier sind, hier sind kleine, kleine Messer drin.
Und es schneidet sich dann selbst in das Kabel rein und stellt Kontakt hin.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich nice.
War mir, war mir zwar irgendwie bewusst, dass es das gibt, aber nie so, nie so wirklich 100%.
Das ist mir nicht klar, bevor das der Chat noch mal empfohlen hat.
Also muss man sagen, richtig massive, massive Brain-Chat.
So, also habe ich jetzt so ein Ding auf die eine Seite gemacht, also hier oben.
Und auf die andere Seite im Keller.
Und dann ist mir eingefallen, ich habe ja noch einen Kabeltester, so ein Ding.
So einen ganz billigen China, China-Chinesen-Kabeltester.
Also das billigste, das billigste, was es gibt.
So was hier.
Das ist, das ist quasi das China-Chinesen-Kabeltester-Teil, wo man den Kabeltester vorher wahrscheinlich erstmal testen muss, ob er richtig testet.
So.
Ich habe einfach ein normales Netzwerkkabel durchgestöpselt und habe den, habe den eingeschaltet und es funktioniert.
Das ist die einfachste Variante überhaupt.
Es leuchtet einfach hier die 1, 2, 3 nacheinander und du musst einfach gucken, ob alle Lichter leuchten.
Das ist der, also das ist der low-brainigste Kabeltester aller Zeiten.
Für das SS habe ich übrigens keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht Reverse oder so.
Ich weiß, keine Ahnung.
Oder vielleicht für das AJ11.
Zumindest, zumindest.
Habe ich den, habe ich das oben und unten dran gemacht.
Und habe den Kabeltester angeschlossen und es hat geblinkt auf 1, 2, 3 nicht, 4, 5, 6, 7 und 8 auch nicht.
So.
Und dann hatte ich das Problem, wo ist jetzt der Fehler?
Oben oder unten?
Also in welchem Stecker habe ich es verkehrt gemacht?
Also habe ich mir gedacht, komm, wenn du gerade schon im Keller bist, wenn du schon im Keller bist, machst du den Stecker im Keller einfach nochmal neu.
Also habe ich den Stecker im Keller neu gemacht.
Also nochmal abgeschnitten.
Im Keller hatte ich auch mehr Kabel noch übrig.
Weil ansonsten das Kabel hier oben, das geht hier quasi durch.
Und es ist nicht mehr so viel Platz.
So, also.
Stecker neu gemacht im Keller.
Wieder angeschlossen.
Immer noch.
Immer noch auf dem Kabeltester.
3 und 8 falsch.
Aber ich werde, okay, zweimal gleich falsch, unfähig anschließen werde ich nicht sein.
Der Fehler liegt oben am Stecker.
Also bin ich hoch und habe den letzten Zentimeter, quasi den ich habe, dass ich es in die Dose bekomme, noch.
Ne, ne, Tester.
Tester ist nicht kaputt.
Der Tester ist nicht kaputt.
Also er hat, das hat schon, hat schon funktioniert.
Ich habe es ja mit einem anderen Kabel vorher getestet.
Das hat das, das ging so also oben hin hierhin.
Das hing dann hier noch raus.
Okay, neu, neu dran gefehlt.
Kabeltester angestöpselt funktioniert nice.
So, und dann habe ich Big Brain Move gemacht.
Ich habe mir hier eine Netzwerkdose draufgesetzt.
Die erste Netzwerkdose, die ich je im Leben selbst selbst gesetzt habe.
Also ich habe im Endeffekt einfach diese, diesen, diesen TAE, diese TAE-Blende abgemacht.
Und habe eine Netzwerkdosenblende draufgemacht mit einem Klipser für so einen, für so einen Keystone-Dings.
Und jetzt habe ich hier eine Netzwerk, Netzwerkdose mit einem Anschluss, wo Keller draufsteht.
Danach habe ich es aber mega verkackt.
Das ist das, wo ich Mist gekauft habe.
Hi, es ist Joji, Dankeschön für zwölf, nein, zwanzig massive Subscription-Monate.
So, und dann habe ich eine Sache echt verkackt.
Ich habe mir doch letztens, ich habe mir doch letztens im Switch, also ganz, ganz zackig den billigsten MikroTik-Switch gekauft, der PoE kann.
Nämlich den hier.
Weil von der Idee her wollte ich das so machen.
Ich schließe hier in, an, ne, ich schließe hier unten nämlich ein Kabel hin.
Mache das dann hier hoch an die Dose, gehe in den Keller.
Wasser-Esser, Dankeschön für den Prime-Sub.
Funktioniert ja auch wunderbar.
Und unten dachte ich mir, das ist ja ein PoE-Router.
Hier.
Hier oben.
Unten dachte ich mir, mache ich dieses, mache ich den PoE, äh, den PoE-Switch dran von MikroTik.
Der hat nämlich PoE in und PoE out.
Und meine Idee war, ich kann den Router über PoE betreiben, also den Switch über PoE betreiben.
Und den Access-Point, da habe ich nämlich so ein Ding für den Keller.
So, und ich dachte mir, ich mache einfach Stromversorgung komplett, komplett übers Netzwerkkabel.
Also, Kabel runtergezogen.
Dann nochmal ganz zum Glück, sonst hätte ich das Ding wahrscheinlich gegrillt, nochmal reingeguckt in die Specs von diesem Switch.
Und da ist mir aufgefallen, der kann nur Input 11 bis 30 Volt, aber PoE ist 48 Volt.
Also, ich habe absolut keine Ahnung, was das hier für ein komisches PoE sein soll.
Wahrscheinlich 24 Volt PoE, was auch immer.
Zumindest mein ganzes PoE und auch die Geräte dran sind 48 Volt.
Das heißt, ich habe mir dieses Ding komplett umsonst.
Und ich habe jetzt keinen Switch im Keller.
Das heißt, ich konnte genau ein Gerät anschließen und das ist mein Access-Point.
Aber das hat funktioniert.
Aber das waren 55 Euro umsonst rausgeschmissenes Geld.
Weil das überhaupt nicht das macht, was ich will.
Aber ich behalte ihn trotzdem.
Weil Switche braucht man immer mal.
Scheiß auf PoE-Funktionalität.
Ja, das habe ich ein bisschen verkackt.
Aber das hat viel länger gedauert, als ich gedacht habe.
Ich habe da bestimmt drei Stunden gestern rumgewurstet.
Bis dieses Kabel von hier...
Anstatt, dass es jetzt hier eine Netzwerkdose ist, in den Keller geht.
Richtig, richtig painstamped gewesen.
Ja, und wo ich dann gerade mal im Keller war, habe ich mich mal wieder...
Wir gucken übrigens gleich Zeug.
Ich muss jetzt mal ein bisschen erzählen, weil es mich gestern so angepainstamped hat.
Habe ich gedacht, okay, wenn du mal im Keller bist, machst du mal Fotos von deinen ganzen Geräten im Keller.
Und ich habe es ja schon lange vor, meine Tür-Gegensprechanlage mit...
Mit den Telefonen zu verbinden.
Ich habe da auch schon verschiedene Anläufe gemacht, aber es hat alles nicht richtig funktioniert.
Und ich habe jetzt mal ein paar Fotos gemacht von den Geräten, die ich da habe.
Also sprich, was das für eine Telefonanlage...
Was das für eine Gegensprechanlage ist und was das für Telefone sind als Gegensprechding im Flur.
So, und da ist mir aufgefallen, okay, das Einfachste ist, die haben was Neues von dem Hersteller.
Die haben jetzt...
Also ich habe so Dinger.
An der Wand hängen für Tür-Gegensprechanlage.
So komische Telefone.
Und was ich jetzt von dem Hersteller...
Passt mal auf, jetzt wird es richtig, richtig painstampig.
Es ist schon richtig weirdchamping, was die da wieder treiben.
So, ich habe jetzt gelesen, die einfachste Variante...
Also die haben jetzt was Neues seit letztem Jahr.
Da muss man gar nichts mehr basteln.
Die einfachste Variante ist einfach so eine Gegenstelle von der Tür-Gegensprechanlage...
Durch eine IP-fähige Gegenstelle.
Gegenstelle auszutauschen.
Gibt es von denen?
Sieht genauso aus.
Nur, dass es das WLAN-Stelz am Start ist.
So, dachte ich mir, eigentlich eine coole Idee.
Und dann habe ich mir das mal angeguckt und ihr könnt euch nicht vorstellen.
Die haben eine gute Idee wirklich maximal verkackt umgesetzt.
Ich weiß nicht, was mit den Herstellern los ist.
Also von der Idee her, schließt du das hier einfach dort an.
Also erstens ist es saumäßig teuer.
Jetzt kommt es ja.
Guckt euch mal den Preis an.
Erstens, das ist das Billigste vom Billigen an Plastik-Analog-Gegensprechanlage überhaupt.
Erstmal 250 Euro.
Okay.
Meinetwegen.
Aber.
Aber jetzt kommt der Hit.
Es ist wirklich maximal painstampig gemacht.
Von der Idee her ist es einfach.
Du nimmst dein altes Tür-Gegensprechsystem, steckst das ab, steckst das Neue dran.
So.
Die zeigen ja auch hier, ja wunderbar, kannst du aufs Smartphone anrufen.
So, jetzt kommt.
Jetzt kommt aber der Hit.
Was ist der Hinweis?
Wir haben sich gedacht, das wäre viel zu einfach, wenn man das Ding einfach konfigurieren könnte,
mit jedem x-beliebigen Zip-Gateway-Voib-Gedöns sprechen zu können.
Dass man da einfach ein Setting reinmacht, dass man sagt, hey, connecte dich zu, was weiß ich,
Zip-Gate, Easy-Bell, was auch immer oder connecte dich zur Fritzbox.
Oder vielleicht sogar einen analogen Telefon-Out oder so.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Nee, nee, das wäre viel zu einfach gewesen.
Das Einzige, mit dem diese Dinger funktionieren, ist, dass du da nicht so viel Zeit hast.
die offizielle app über die offiziellen server von dem vom hersteller also du kannst du kannst
dieses ding nicht verwenden mit einer fritz box mit irgendeinem explizit anbieter du kannst nur
über die offiziellen server das machen und du kannst das nur über die offizielle app verwenden
und nur auf android ios also an decktelefone oder so dass das die telefon im haus klingen
weiterleiten geht damit gar nicht du könntest dann höchstens irgendwie vom telefon oder so
vielleicht weiterleiten keine ahnung und du bist angewiesen auf die server des herstellers sprich
wenn dein internet nicht geht dann klingeln auch deine ganze telefon nicht also es ist jetzt nicht
irgendwie somit mit mit mit decktelefon es ist so unglaublich bescheuert warum baut man dann sowas
gut ich weiß warum man sowas baut weil weil wenn du ein login weil wenn du ein login was was sonst
aber es ist es ist einfach nur weirdchamp wie man so ein müll wie man so einen müll bauen kann an
sich eine richtig gute hinsicht
idee und 250 euro fucking teuer aber es funktioniert einfach nicht so wie man das
haben will wo ist das problem ich meine das ding kann bluetooth und wlan man könnte wlan man könnte
config über bluetooth machen okay man könnte einfach konfigurieren webinterface machen man
gibt sein zip gateway ein und es funktioniert warum sollte deckt aussterben also avm hat was
dagegen das deckt ausstirbt die man ja ganze smart home zeug überdeckt aber es ist es ist einfach hey
das hat mich so abgefuckt weil ich mir gesagt das wäre die einfachste variante das wäre die
einfachste variante gewesen das verbteillich anzuschließen aber nein der hersteller denkt
sich mal wieder wenn der logan ist wichtiger als sinnvolle funktionen hey smith ist man
sind ich weiß nicht kennst du dich mit sowas aus kennst du dich mit so was aus weil ich hab
lustigerweise genau das gleiche gefunden und war vorhin auf ebay dann habe ich mein ebay ebay ebay
geguckt und auf ebay gibt sie dinge sogar relativ relativ günstig kann man
sich zum beispiel 44 130 euro so ein ding kaufen
mir egal ob das gebraucht ist oder nicht ich hatte ich hatte ich hatte ich
habe schon ein paar versuche gemacht meine tür gegensprechanlage zu verbinden
mit den decktelefon ich habe auch mal so was hier ausprobiert das ist nicht
heuer das ist eigentlich ganz leises gerät gewesen
ab du hast da das sieht anders aus dass da sowas hier das ist eigentlich ein
ganz neues gerät gewesen aber auch wenn es ein bisschen anders aussieht im
prinzip ist es das alter können immer gescheiter fotos machen please gibt es
da vielleicht ordentliche ordentliche ordentliche bilder von hier bilder gibt
davon nicht das ist eigentlich auch eine ganz gute
idee
das gerät für tür gegensprechanlagen da hier erkennt man es ganz gut das
eigentlich ganz einfach du klemmst hier die die die zwei drähte von diesem
siedler kommentar gegen sprechding an irgendwo hier glaube ich und hier machst
du dann hier machst du dein telefon dran das problem an diesem teil war nur dass
es gerauscht hat und das wenn man die tele wenn man wenn man beide telefone an
der wand dran gelassen hat dann war das ultra leise
jetzt meinen wir uns mit denen in macht overlap zu handeln und es N graduates
einfach glück forma hast du von meinem phone kali
simon الا
davon aus, es wird nicht sonderlich schwierig sein.
Wie ist das damit? Kann man damit direkt
das Gespräch annehmen am Telefon
oder muss man erst irgendeine Vorwahl machen?
Oder irgendeinen Code eingeben?
So.
Das musste ich euch jetzt mal erzählen. Also richtig,
richtig Painschamped hier.
Gestern, deswegen habe ich gestern auch nicht gestreamt,
mit Netzwerkkabel in den
Keller. Aber es funktioniert alles, da bin
ich jetzt wirklich froh drüber.
Es war aber mehr Painschamped
als gedacht.
Und zumindest habe ich jetzt hier eine
Netzwerkdose. Mit einem
ganzen Port.
Man könnte daraus natürlich auch
200 Mbit Ports machen, wenn man denn
will. Ja.
Ich glaube, ich bestelle mir auf Ebay mal so
ein Ding und probiere das aus.
Muss mal einen Painschamped Counter machen, ja.
Und was mich auch verwirrt hat,
was mir zum ersten Mal
so wirklich bewusst geworden
ist, wusstet ihr, dass es zwei
verschiedene Varianten gibt,
wie man Aeon 45 Stecker
verkabelt. Warum gibt es
da zwei Varianten?
Ne, ne, ne, nicht Crossover. Ne, ne, ne, das
meine ich nicht.
Es gibt, es gibt
T568B
und T568A.
Warum?
Warum gibt es da schon wieder zwei Stück?
Was denken die sich immer dabei?
Warum muss es für alle irgendwie zwei Sachen geben?
Tür öffnen geht auch mit
einem Code. Ah, nice. Gut, Türöffner
habe ich keinen. Das brauche ich nicht. Aber ist gut zu wissen.
Also Smart in 7.9.
Wenn du das nächste Mal wieder im Stream bist und ich das Ding
schon angeschlossen habe, musst du dich vielleicht nochmal nerven
mit irgendwelchen Sachen.
Hat das nicht was mit
PoE zu tun? Ne, PoE geht beides.
Es ist vollkommen egal,
es ist vollkommen egal, was man
verkabelt. Es ist
nur wichtig, dass man beide Seiten
immer gleich verkabelt. Ich habe es jetzt mit B
gemacht, ja. Ich habe es auch mit B gemacht.
Aber warum ist da schon wieder
zu... Seid mal ernsthaft. Hat jemand von euch eine Idee?
Warum gibt es zwei? War vielleicht
A zuerst da und man hat festgestellt,
A ist unvorteilhaft und es gibt jetzt
B und B hat sich dann
mehr etabliert. Also ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ach, eine Seite
A und eine Seite B, dann hast du Crossover.
Ach, so ist das gemacht. Okay.
Also sprich, die zwei gibt es,
dass man weiß, wie man
Crossover-Kabel machen kann.
Wurde ja schon mal
RJ Keystone, RJ45
in den Raum gekauft. Ja, habe ich sogar offen. Guck mal da.
Damit habe ich das angeschlossen gestern.
Kabel hier
aus dem Kabelkanal raus von dem komischen
Telekom-Ding abgemacht.
Ein Keystone, RJ45 drauf.
In den Keller runter, abgeschnitten.
Auch ein Keystone, RJ45 drauf.
Ja, dafür habe ich das
nämlich gebraucht.
Weil, weil, so einfach ist das natürlich nicht.
Weil natürlich meine Kabel
etwas paint-champig
ähm
befarbt
waren, ja. Also ich hatte beispielsweise
kein, also in meinem
Netzwerkkabel, ich hatte
kein, ähm,
ähm,
ähm, ähm.
weiß, orange. Ich hatte
orange und weiß
zusammen gedreht. Das heißt, ich
musste immer gucken, dass ich das schön nacheinander
aufmache, weil sonst hätte ich nicht mehr
gefunden, welches weiße Kabel gehört jetzt zu
welcher Farbe. Also die machen einem
teilweise hardware-technisch echt das Leben
schwer. Anstatt sich
einfach mal an sowas zu halten.
Was, Türöffner brauchst du trotzdem?
Ja, ja, nee, nee, nee.
Was ich meine ist, ich habe keine Türöffner.
Deswegen brauche ich das nicht.
So war das gemeint. Also ich brauche diese Funktion nicht,
weil ich meine Tür keinen Türöffner
habe. Okay.
Ja, mischen geht natürlich
nicht.
Zumal Cross-Over-Kabel
und so, das ist ja heute mittlerweile zum
größten Teil eh alles automatische Erkennung.
Da ist es nicht wild.
Ich sage euch, Leute,
ich habe seit meiner Ausbildung
nicht mal so viel rumgefuddelt
Netzwerkkabel-technisch wie gestern,
aber es funktioniert. Ich würde euch jetzt gerne ein
Foto sogar von zeigen, aber ich habe keins gemacht.
Aber gut, ich könnte jetzt hintergehen
eins machen, aber es ist relativ unspektakulär.
Anstatt so einer TAE-Dose ist da jetzt einfach noch
eine dritte Netzwerkdose. Das muss ich jetzt glaube ich nicht
fotografieren. Das kann man sich glaube ich
vorstellen. Du hattest doch mal eine Ausbildung
zu... Ja, habe ich. Ich habe
meine Ausbildung vor zwei Monaten bei den Bindern tatsächlich noch
über dein Video von der IHK-Prüfung
gestolpert. Ja, ich hoffe bei dir hat alles funktioniert.
Bei mir hat es ja
nicht geklappt so richtig.
Danach schon, aber erst mal ein bisschen
Schock, von wegen sie sind durchgefallen.
Naja, gut.
Genug über Kabel und Sachen
gelabert. Damit war ich gestern
beschäftigt, deswegen habe ich auch nicht gestreamt. Aber ich bin froh,
dass es funktioniert. Ich sage euch Leute,
WLAN, endlich richtig gut
im Haus. Bis auf der
Terrassenseite.
Ich habe jetzt
einen...
Alter, ich habe irgendwas im Hals.
Hypergachi.
So, ich glaube
jetzt reicht mal was trinken.
Also,
wie viel Kram macht man als Fachinformatiker
eigentlich so?
Kommt auf die Firma an. Also kommt auf den Betrieb
an, wo man ist. In der Regel
machst du als Fachinformatiker
Systemintegration mehr
Netzwerk- und Hardware-Sachen als ein Anwendungsentwickler.
Aber die Ausbildungen nehmen sich echt nicht
mehr so viel. Das sieht man auch daran, dass
Berufsschulen und Prüfungen zum größten Teil gleich sind.
Ich hatte Glück mit meinen Prüfern.
Ich habe was... Windows-Server.
Und die Prüfer waren richtige
Linux-Profi. Ich wäre mit Linux zerstört von dem
Fachgespräch. Na, oder du hättest Pluspunkte,
bekommen, weil die Linux-Fans sind.
Und die hätten keine Ahnung von Windows.
Ja, was ich sagen wollte.
WLAN, richtig gut jetzt. Ich habe im
Keller, über dieses neue Kabel jetzt,
einen
URP-Light.
Dann habe ich im Erdgeschoss,
sind verschiedene Generationen, weil ich die verschieden aufgerüstet habe,
habe ich einen URP-Pro im Erdgeschoss.
Da ist übrigens auch der Raspberry Pi dran.
Und oben habe ich den Nano-HD. Also ich habe jetzt drei
drei
Unify-Access-Points.
Und ich muss sagen, jetzt, seitdem ich auf
jeder Etage den Access-Point habe,
jetzt ist das WLAN zum ersten Mal im
ganzen Haus wirklich richtig
gut. Was ich nicht ganz verstehe
ist, warum
sich die WLAN-Lampe
im Wohnzimmer, also quasi im Raum,
neben dem ich jetzt hier sitze, die
WLAN-Lampe im ersten Stock
aus dem Wohnzimmer
sich mit dem Access-Point
im Keller verbindet.
Das ist mir
nicht so ganz klar.
Aber sie macht es und sie funktioniert.
Also ich kann
alle Clients nachvollziehen, wie die sich
verbinden. Der Raspberry Pi im Keller
verbindet sich zum Access-Point im Keller.
Die Kamera im Keller verbindet sich
zum Access-Point im Keller.
Alles gut, alles klar, verstehe ich.
Die Tasmota-Steckdose verbindet
sich zum Access-Point. Alles klar.
Das Einzige, was absolut
bescheuert ist, warum verbindet sich
die
WLAN-RGB-Lampe,
die am weitesten entfernt ist,
zum Access-Point im Keller?
Anstatt zum Access-Point im Raum nebendran
oder zum Access-Point im Erdgeschoss?
Nein, die geht zum Access-Point im Keller.
Obwohl sie da plus 65%
Empfang hat.
Keine Ahnung. Verstehe ich nicht, aber sie macht es
und sie funktioniert.
Die Logik verstehe ich eh nicht so genau. Aber hey,
solange das alles funktioniert, ist das kein Ding.
Chat, Chat, ich weiß doch,
ihr seid MassiveBrain.
Kennt ihr ein
gutes
System, um
Bilderkennung zu machen für analoge,
äh,
Anzeigen, also zum Beispiel
Wasser,
sowas da.
Kennt ihr irgendein gutes Bilderkennungssystem,
was sowas hier,
sowas hier auslesen kann?
So Nadelstände.
Ich rede nicht hier von Zahlen, von
Nadelständen.
Wie gesagt, ich wollte das, ich wollte
das ja ausprobieren, mal
on stream mit meinem
Stromzähler.
Aber für
die Druckanzeige an der
Heizung habe ich schon eine Kamera davor.
Das würde ich jetzt gerne
bilderkennen. Also ich habe
da schon eine Kamera vor. Ich bräuchte jetzt irgendeine
Massive, äh, trainierte
AI-Geschichte,
die das erkennen kann.
Ja, ich hatte mal was gezeigt, das geht
aber über einen ESP mit Kamera,
den du da vorhängen musst. Und wenn ich schon eine
Kamera habe, habe ich mir gedacht, ich kann den zusätzlichen
ESP neben der Kamera noch eine Kamera
quasi, ähm, sparen.
Ja, das kann auch, ob das mit
TensorFlow ist oder mit was auch immer, ist mir
egal. Ich will aber, dass das schon
vortrainiert ist und am besten irgendeinen
Webserver dabei hat, wo ich einfach nur
meine Bilder hinschicken
muss und der gibt mir als JSON
zurück, keine Ahnung, 0,5.
Das wäre mir ehrlich gesagt am
liebsten. Aber ich gehe mal davon
aus, sowas gibt es wahrscheinlich nicht fertig.
Aber das wäre äußerst praktisch.
Da könnte ich nämlich in
mein Home Assistant einfach einbinden, auf der
Startseite, äh, Wasserdruck in der
Heizung.
Ohne, dass ich auf die Kamera gucken muss.
Hätte ja sein können,
dass einer von euch eine Ahnung hat. Wie gesagt,
ja, das kenne ich, das kenne ich. Das ist auch das,
was ich hier gerade gezeigt habe.
Ich will es ja nicht mit dem ESP32 machen.
Da, da müsste ja eine Kamera neben
eine Kamera hängen. Das ist ja auch doof.
Okay, dann würde ich sagen, gucken wir mal
ein paar Bits. Ja,
denkt sich die Lampe echt. Also, was auch immer.
Es ist, es ist komplett bescheuert,
dass die Lampe aus dem ersten Stock mit dem
Access Point im Keller verbindet. Aber,
meinetwegen.
Anyline. Was ist denn Anyline? Kenne ich nicht.
Things that schon exist. Zeig mal her.
Internet Explorer for Unix. Ja, gut, noch.
Das habe ich schon mal gesehen. Da habe ich, glaube
ich, sogar mal überlegt, ob ich ein Video zu
machen sollte. Oh, hier, Big Brain Time Chat.
Ups, will es kopieren? Copy, pasten? Genau, genau
sowas.
Genau sowas.
Genau sowas will ich machen.
Bla, bla, bla. Ja, hier hat er seine Kamera oben drüber.
Ja, das brauche ich alles nicht. Ich habe ja schon
ein Kamerabild. Ich habe ja schon ein Kamerabild.
Das brauche ich alles nicht. OpenCV Part.
Aha. Wow. Monka.
Okay. Was zum? To make everything work well isn't that easy.
Ja, das habe ich mir schon gedacht. Scripts and source code.
Water meter code. Okay, das wurde ewig nicht
aktualisiert. Oh, ach du Scheiße. Quick Maths.
Nee, da habe ich keinen Bock drauf. Da brauche ich
irgendwas Fertiges. Das mache ich nicht selbst.
Da bin ich ein halbes Jahr beschäftigt.
Quick Maths hier. Alles klar. Easy. Ich glaube, so
kompliziert ist das gar nicht. Ah, die Hull Points.
Alles, alles klar. Ja, ich glaube, das gebe ich mir
nicht. Zeit für Wasserzähler as a Service. Sehr gute Idee.
Was ist denn das? Things that shouldn't exist.
21 Minuten. What the fuck?
I. Es ist allen Ernstes Internet Explorer. Es ist Internet Explorer.
Und warum? Warum? Das ist doch nicht das, was ich gesehen habe.
Aber eigentlich eine gute Idee, das mal auszuprobieren.
So mal ein bisschen Zeug zeigen, was Microsoft getrieben hat vor 30 Jahren.
Naja. So, also. Gucken wir mal kurz im Chat.
Und gucken wir mal ein paar Witz. Echt nicht?
Das Problem. Also ich habe relativ viele Kabel gemacht in der Ausbildung.
Gut, ich habe auch beim Provider gearbeitet.
Wir waren öfters im Rechenzentrum. Also da hat man ab und zu mal Kabel gemacht.
Aber ich war da auch kein großer Fan von.
Was ist deine Meinung zu GitHub Copilot? Das ist Spielerei.
Ich weiß, es gibt da die Verschwörung.
Die Verschwörungstheorie. Was heißt Verschwörungstheorie?
Die Vermutung, Microsoft möchte alle Programmierer arbeitslos machen, indem sie sich quasi selbst wegtrainieren.
Also die Leute programmieren, checken es bei GitHub ein. GitHub trainiert Copilot, sodass man irgendwann keine Programmierer mehr braucht.
Da habe ich so meine Zweifel.
Ob das der Fall sein wird.
Ich habe nie einen Ausfall produziert im großen Stil.
Den größten Ausfall, den ich mal produziert habe, ist durch einen Wackelkontakt von einem Kabel.
Ich habe nie einen Ausfall produziert im großen Stil. Den größten Ausfall, den ich mal produziert habe, ist durch einen Wackelkontakt von einem Kabel.
Zum ESX.
Aber da konnte ich nichts für.
Und man ..
Das war eigentlich lustig!
Mein jetziger Chef
war damals zuständig für ESXe.
Und hat noch zu mir gesagt, mach mal die und die Kabel raus.
Hab ich gemacht.
Die ausbildung noch.
Und Kabel drum herum rund umher oder sonst, wir hatten irgendwie Wackelkontakt.
Und deswegen hat der ESX Cluster genommen, um die Kabel reinzuziehen.
Und meint, die fliegen jetzt mal aus dem Cluster raus und dann war dann irgendwie 40 VMs nicht mehr erreichbar.
Das war der größte Ausfall, den ich je produziert habe.
Aber da konnte ich nichts für Loop stecken.
Da sollte ja normalerweise nichts passieren.
Ich habe schon das Gegenteil erlebt.
Dass Switches Sachen im Kreis schicken.
Das habe ich schon mit auch teuren Cisco Switches.
Aber normalerweise sollte es ja nicht passieren.
Wir hatten übrigens auch mal lustigerweise das Problem, dass gerade das, was diesen Loop verhindern soll,
das ist ja normalerweise so, wenn du Switche an Switche an Switche an Switche steckst
und die miteinander verkabelst, dann gibt es so etwas, das nennt sich Spanning Tree.
Das guckt, dass du keine Schleifen baust.
Und wenn du ein relativ großes Layer 2 Netz hast, dann kann das passieren,
dass Spanning Tree, also du stöpselst was und Spanning Tree baut sich neu auf,
dass das Minuten braucht.
Das hatten wir auch mal das Problem.
Dann...
Dann ging das Netzwerk quasi irgendwie drei Minuten nicht, weil Spanning Tree erst mal aufbauen musste.
Ja.
Das...
Alles schon mal...
Ja, das kenne ich, das kenne ich.
Das habe ich doch schon im Stream gezeigt.
Das kenne ich.
Die Sache ist die, ich will ja kein ESP davor hängen.
Ich habe ja schon ein Bild von der Kamera da unten.
Das heißt, ich will jetzt nicht die Kamera und dann noch ein ESP daneben hängen.
Kann man das eigentlich...
Kann man das Kamerabild eigentlich per RTSP abgreifen?
Oder MJPS?
Oder JPEG oder so?
Kann man hiervon irgendwie das Bild abgreifen?
Weil das wäre auch eine Option.
Wie auch immer.
Ich würde sagen...
Wir fangen mal an.
Wir gucken jetzt ein paar Witz.
Das Ding machen wir dazu.
Leider gibt es heute irgendwie auf YouTube nur Mist.
Ich habe ein bisschen...
Was ist das denn?
Hier.
Alles klar.
Weißt du eigentlich, warum es wie es Code bei GitHub gibt?
Wie jetzt?
Warum soll es das nicht geben?
Also was verwirrt dich daran, dass es büchle-studio-code bei GitHub gibt?
Kennt jemand eine gute Möglichkeit, diese Twitch-Wortsperre zu umgehen?
Ne, habe ich mich noch nie mit beschäftigt.
Da komme ich jetzt nicht mit.
Zu big-brainer-Chat für mich schon.
Fehlen noch ein paar Prime-Subs, dass mein IQ erweitert wird, wenn ich das verstehe.
So.
Also es gibt keine gescheiten Videos, die mir empfohlen wurden.
Also kaum.
Kaum.
Deswegen ist das Erste, was wir uns jetzt angucken müssen,
nein, das da nicht.
Ähm.
Wir lassen es...
Den habe ich übrigens noch nicht geguckt.
Den können wir uns heute mal zusammen...
Wahrscheinlich.
Ich meine, es haben 2,3 Millionen Leute geguckt.
Ihr habt den Battlefield-Shortfilm sicherlich schon gesehen, ne?
Was bei GitHub?
Punkt drücken?
Was zum...
Was wollt ihr von mir?
Punkt.
Excellent.
So, ich gehe mal zu mir in...
Und jetzt?
Soll ich...
Soll ich auschecken?
Punkt.
Login?
Ne, kann er jetzt nicht machen.
Okay.
Das ist mir zu high IQ.
Komme ich gerade nicht mit.
Je baited.
You got je baited.
GitHub kann Repos in Online-VS-Code öffnen.
Ach so.
Alter.
Ihr müsst sowas schon schreiben, dass man es als normalsterblicher versteht.
Ach so.
Ja, jetzt.
Okay, jetzt habe ich es gecheckt.
Warum?
Ja gut, was sich GitHub dabei gedacht hat, weiß ich nicht.
Aber...
Das ist von der gleichen Firma.
Also GitHub gehört zu Microsoft.
Visual Studio Code gehört zu Microsoft.
Dass die versuchen, da so eine Online-Bearbeitungsgeschichte aufzubauen,
war ja spätestens seit GitHub...
Wie hieß das?
GitHub Spaces oder so?
Äh, klar, dass die was in der Richtung probieren.
Das wundert mich jetzt nicht.
Dass man immer mehr Edit-Möglichkeiten auf GitHub bekommt.
Gut, also.
Was schauen wir uns jetzt an?
Das muss ich mir gar nicht angucken.
Wetten, dass das Kokona-Haus...
Also, also.
Prediction, Prediction.
Er will 10 Gigabit in sein Haus einbauen.
Wetten, der nimmt jetzt gleich eine Schere und schneidet ein Loch in die Wand?
Oder eine Säge und schneidet ein Loch in die Wand?
Richtig, das ist 100% richtiges Kokona-Haus.
Passt mal auf, passt mal auf.
Ich wette mit euch, dass...
Ja, ja, okay.
Okay, Moment.
Mal gucken, ob ich richtig liege.
Und letztens...
Ich werde Gigabit-Fiber holen, damit dieses 120-Jährige-Haus sehr schnell fliegt.
Und ich werde euch zeigen...
Ich muss...
Hell yeah, hey, Mann.
Die Amis wieder, Alter.
Die Amis wieder.
Einfach mal mit der Säge ein Loch in die Wand schneiden.
Viel Spaß.
Ja, ja, kein Problem.
Mach das mal in einem ordentlichen Haus hier.
Wobei, der hat zumindest die Außenwände.
Die Außenwände scheinen zumindest immer noch Stein zu sein bei dem.
Ja, dann ist es kein Problem, neue Dosen in die Wand zu machen, wenn du einfach nur eine Säge brauchst.
Nein, kann ich nicht, weil mein Haupt ist aus Stein.
Doch, doch, es ist im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes hart.
Gut, das muss man sich ja nicht angucken.
Das ist Kokona-Style-Umbau.
Ja.
Ja, super.
Einfach mal Löcher in die Wand schneiden.
So mag ich das.
Okay, da lassen wir uns jetzt ein bisschen Level-Capture-Baden.
Wir lassen uns ein bisschen Level-Capture-Baden.
Also, schief los.
Wer hätte das gedacht, dass der Playtest Data-Mined wird?
Da hätte man ja gar nicht mit rechnen können.
Ich meine, Data-Mined ist...
Das ist eh nur ein Fancy-Word von...
Man extrahiert Strings und Sachen aus den gepackten Dateien.
Also, Data-Mined hört sich immer so wahnsinnig, so wahnsinnig Big-Brain an.
Ja, ist das Dings hier?
Ist das der Kurzfilm?
Die gucken wir uns wirklich mal an.
Sieht nice aus.
Ja.
Ist das der Typ aus Battlefield 4?
Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern?
Wartet mal.
Big17 jetzt, für Altersfreigaben-Videos.
Das ist der 100% Dude aus Battlefield 4.
Du musst angemeldet sein.
um es zu benutzen? Ja, denkst du, denkst du.
Muss ich nicht.
Der alte angemeldet sein Hack
funktioniert immer noch. Einfach auf Embedded
umschalten. Easy.
Das ist der Typ aus dem Auto am Anfang, ja.
Und weißt du, wisst ihr, was ich cool finde?
Ich hab zum Release, irgendwann,
in irgendeinem, wo wir uns die
Gameplay-Trailer zusammen angeguckt haben,
hab ich doch noch
gesagt, ey, der eine Typ,
ich weiß nicht, der eine soll da irgendwas...
Der Typ sieht aus wie der aus dem Battlefield Singleplayer.
Und wahrscheinlich hat man das
da schon gesehen.
Egal, wir lassen uns jetzt weiter von Levelcaptcha bähen.
Lohnt sich der Film,
lohnt sich der Kurzfilm überhaupt anzugucken?
Also ich muss sagen, ich fand die Overwatch-Kurzfilme
immer nice.
Was ich halt cool fand, dass die Overwatch-Kurzfilme
so ein bisschen, äh,
wie sagt man so, so leicht,
sagt man so, leichtherzig, sagt man das auf Deutsch
auch so, halt so,
jetzt nicht, nicht, nicht so,
nicht so ernst waren.
Übrigens, das ist auch so ein Ding,
da muss ich noch mal kurz was zu sagen.
Also, als erstes
hieß es, der Battlefield-Playtest,
der wäre zwei bis drei Monate alt.
So, danach hat
der Ober-Battlefield-Leaker,
wie hieß er, Tom
Henderson,
äh, Bill H...
H...
äh,
der hat, der hat irgendwas geschrieben,
ja, also,
er hat erst geschrieben,
er hat erst geschrieben, äh,
das Playtest-Bild ist drei bis vier Monate alt,
bla bla bla, Polly, und dann hat er gesagt,
Info is wrong, Bild is actually
from 29.
Juli.
Die Sache ist halt die, dass das überhaupt
nix miteinander zu tun hat. Ich mein,
das hier ist, wo irgendwie mal ein,
ein Bild-Job gelaufen ist
und hat den Kram kompiliert.
Ich mein, wir kennen,
wir kennen ihre Pipeline nicht, wir kennen ihre Build-Skripts
oder sonst was nix, äh,
kennen das nicht, also keine Ahnung, ob der das Datum
vom letzten
Commit nimmt, ob das hardcoded ist
oder ob der einfach den,
das aktuelle Datum vom Bild-Vorgang
nimmt, aber nur, weil
das Bild
am 29.
Juli passiert ist, heißt das noch lange nicht,
dass das auch vom 29.
Juli ist.
Der Source-Code ist garantiert von diesem
Test, der ist Monate alt.
Wenn drei bis vier Monate überhaupt ausreichen,
es ist auch eindeutig irgendein
Test-Bild, das siehst du, die Beleuchtung
ist überhaupt nicht richtig in dem Game drinnen,
die Sachen sind teilweise sehr hakelig,
du siehst noch irgendwie Umrisse an Stellen, wo du
keine sehen sollst, also, äh,
Bobat
SH, Dankeschön für den Prime-Sub,
also das ist auf jeden Fall kein Bild
von einem Battlefield, was in, äh,
zwei Monaten rauskommt, was, was, was wir da
gesehen haben, ja, also auch nicht, auch nicht hier vom
29. Also,
ähm,
ich persönlich gehe,
davon aus, also, so wie ich das machen würde, ist,
ich sage, okay, wir wollen einen
Playtest machen, das heißt, es gibt eh
schon mal zwei grundsätzliche Komponenten.
Du hast einmal den Client für das Game,
der ist am 29. kompiliert worden
und du hast die Server-Seite, die Server-Seite wird
natürlich deutlich neuer sein,
als die, als die Client-Seite,
in dem Fall.
An der, an der Server-Seite werden die
permanent, permanent, äh, rum, rumbasteln.
So, also wie ich das
machen würde, ist, ich weiß,
okay, wir wollen, wir wollen einen, einen
Playtest machen oder eine Beta machen oder was
auch immer, das heißt, ich
nehme einen Stand, der aktuell
halbwegs funktioniert.
Also sprich, ich gucke mir einfach
so mal die letzten Tage durch,
welcher Stand, welchen
Stand hatten wir denn da, der am
ehesten irgendwie spielbar ist oder
den man am ehesten in irgendwas Spielbares
umbauen kann.
Dann mache ich mir einen eigenen Branch
auf, was weiß ich, äh, Playtest
und dann
picke ich da oder
fixe ich da nur die Sachen drin,
die wirklich essentiell
sind für diesen
Playtest.
So, und vielleicht war das letzte Commit da drin
am 29. Juli.
So, und dann drückt
irgendwann einer
paar Tage oder paar Wochen
bevor, jaja, ist gut für Nuss,
bevor der Playtest anfängt, auf den
Jetzt-Kompilieren-Button, dann muss
das ja Ganze noch verifiziert werden, in Origin
eingecheckt werden und sonst was.
Und der
Stand unten drunter, nur, also was ich
sagen will, nur weil die das, weil da
steht, der Bild ist vom 29.,
heißt es noch lange nicht, dass der
Source-Code-Stand vom 29. ist, weil das ist
ja garantiert nicht, wahrscheinlich ist er sogar
noch älter, weil die sich
drauf vorbereitet haben, den Playtest zu machen.
Und das genommen haben, was eben
der, äh, spielbarste
Stand ist, den sie haben und den dann so weit
hingestre... hingedreht,
ähm,
dass es, dass es spielbar ist.
Max erwähnt seinen Stream viel zu wenig in Videos.
Ja, müsste, müsste, müsste öfter Sellout machen,
das stimmt. Richtig.
Ja.
Also, ich gehe davon aus, dass hier
stimmt, vielleicht sogar noch ein bisschen älter, 3-4 Monate
erscheint sind. Also, ich gehe davon aus, er hat
mit beiden Sachen recht. Der
eigentliche Code, die, also
so die Basis dürfte, mit ein paar
Comments als Ausnahme, dürfte 3-4 Monate
alt sein, aber das Bild mag vom 29.
sein. So, weiter geht's.
...what the current plans are for Hazard Zone,
but I have a feeling that a lot
of it probably holds up. Throughout
Battlefield V's lifespan, Temporial found tons
of content that hinted at features that...
Ja, ich werde oftmals, witzigerweise,
YouTube-Abonnenten empfohlen auf Twitch.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das
Google und Besos
untereinander so ausmachen. Keine Ahnung.
...while DICE never released.
So, basically take all of this as
pure speculation that
may never make it into the game.
According to Temporial, Hazard Zone will
be a mix of Escape from Tarkov
and Hunt Showdown. Aha.
...the mode will not have... Aha.
Das würde tatsächlich
Sinn ergeben zu dem, was die auch
in dieser FAQ-Session
gesagt haben. Also, Hazard Zone haben
sie angekündigt mit High-Stakes
Squadplay und sie haben in der
FAQ-Session auch öfter sowas in der Richtung
erzählt. Sie wollten aber nicht
im Detail darauf eingehen, weil sie haben gesagt,
ähm,
das wird zu einem späteren Zeitpunkt vorgestellt.
Sie haben dann quasi die Sache nochmal wiederholt.
Ja, das ist quasi High-Intense
Blablabla Squadplay, aber heute
geht's um All-Out-Warfare und Battlefights.
Field. Ähm, 2042
so der Core-Spiel-Modus.
Das ergibt Sinn, weil wir haben
die. Leute, ihr könnt euch nicht vorstellen,
also ich war, ich war ja auf zwei Events,
wo es danach jeweils ungefähr eine Stunde
lang noch Frage und Antwort mit Dice gab.
Und ihr könnt euch nicht vorstellen.
Ratet mal, oder doch, ihr könnt's euch vorstellen.
Ratet mal, was mindestens 50%
der Fragen waren. Mindestens 50%.
Also, wenn nicht sogar 60-70%.
Ja, das wurde auch ab und zu gefragt,
aber nicht so oft.
Battle Royale, korrekt.
Mindestens 50% der Fragen,
wie sieht's mit Battle Royale aus?
Und sie haben halt immer wieder betont,
sie sagen nix dazu, sie sagen nix dazu,
bis er mega pisst war irgendwann,
weil er nur noch nach Battle Royale gefragt wird
und hat gesagt, zum Release wird
Battlefield kein Battle Royale
enthalten.
Und das ergibt Sinn.
Auf der einen Seite schreiben sie,
also diese Meldung ergibt Sinn.
Auf der einen Seite hatten sie so ganz groß
was erzählt von High-Stakes-Squad-Gameplay
und auf der anderen Seite
kein Battle Royale.
Das heißt, dass so eine Mischung aus
Escape from Tarkov und Hunt Showdown kommt
in Hazard Zone, das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Und ich hab ja im Vorfeld gesagt,
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
dass sie quasi diese Battle Royale-Geschichte
schleifen lassen,
nachdem Warzone so gut angekommen ist.
Aber ich könnte mir gut vorstellen,
Alter, ich hab immer noch was im Hals, das ist heute echt der Wahnsinn.
So, aber...
Ich könnte mir gut vorstellen,
dass sie versuchen, einen eigenen
Spin diesem ganzen Battle Royale-Zeug
zu geben. Dankeschön, 100 Millionen Euro.
Poggers, jetzt bin ich reich.
Massive, danke Wolle. 604.
Und ich glaube, das ist der eigene
Spin.
Es ist kein richtig klassischer
Battle Royale, aber es ist ein bisschen
per Battle Royale
das Battlefield.
Vielleicht.
Ich bin gespannt.
Ich bin echt gespannt.
Sie versuchen ja, auf mehreren
Gleisen zu fahren. Sie versuchen, eine klassische
Battlefield-Experience mit All-Out-Warfare
zu machen. Das hier könnte ich mir
vorstellen, ist so ein bisschen für die
Streaming
und E-Sport und
Competitive-Fraktion.
Weil normales Battlefield
zuzugucken auf Twitch ist jetzt nicht so spannend.
Also Battle Royale zuzugucken, deswegen ist das ja auch
so erfolgreich geworden.
Ist schon spannender als normales Battlefield.
Und, ähm, ja, dann
gibt's mit Portal noch was für die Bastler.
Playtest Map Orbital
has built-in support for Hazard Zone.
So it doesn't appear that Hazard Zone
will have some sort of custom, unique map
for it. As for the promo image
for Hazard Zone, you start a match
by inserting via Little Bird
Helicopter. You can purchase...
Aber die haben doch schon Apex
als Battle Royale-Game. Würden die sich nicht selber
Konkurrenz machen? Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob
Battlefield und Apex,
obwohl es in Battle Royale, ich mein, die haben auch
Firestorm gemacht, ja, darf man nicht vergessen,
ob sich das so überschneidet. Also ich
sehe erstens den Grund nicht, warum man
nicht beide spielen soll.
Und ich
sehe die Überschneidung gar nicht so
großartig.
Apex ist eher das Quake
der Battle Royales, ja,
wohingegen Battlefield eindeutig eher
gegen Warzone
Competitive-mäßig antritt.
Also ich sehe da jetzt zwar,
natürlich Überschneidung, und es werden sicherlich
auch die gleichen Leute beide spielen,
aber wenn ich sagen würde,
okay, wenn du so die zwei Gruppen hast,
du hast die Apex-Gruppe,
also auf Huge Pain Skills,
also du hast
keine Ahnung, du hast hier so die
Apex-Gruppe und du hast hier so die
Battlefield-Gruppe, dann würde ich sagen,
das überschneidet
sich vielleicht
vielleicht so.
Ja,
aber die hier bleiben exklusiv Apex,
die hier bleiben exklusiv Battlefield,
und du hast in der Mitte bestimmt ein paar,
wo das dann auch nacheinander abwandern werden,
aber ich glaube, so viel ist das gar nicht.
Ja.
Das ist soography Cerra,
also loitudes,
man sagt,
acerca
you.
Isn't your own?
What's your gameplay?
Ja, Rico, das stimmt.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass die können das Streaming im Jahr 2021
einfach nicht links liegen lassen.
Das ist so.
Die müssen erstens gucken,
dass das Spiel in irgendeiner Art und Weise interessant ist für Streamer.
Also du lässt einfach so extrem, so mega viel Potenzial liegen,
wenn du heute nicht irgendwie versuchst,
also bei so großen Games,
ich rede jetzt nicht von irgendwie 2-Mann-Indie-Steam-Spielen oder so,
weil wenn so große Games nicht versuchen,
in irgendeiner Art und Weise Streaming anzusprechen,
das ist einfach extrem viel verschenktes Potenzial heutzutage.
Und natürlich der nächste Punkt ist,
wenn sich Streamer dafür interessieren,
dann musst du gucken, dass sie das auch halbwegs spielen können.
Gerade bei großen Streamern,
und das muss ja nicht mal so groß sein wie Montana Black,
das kann ja auch, nehm mal den Lost,
der hat nicht so viele Zuschauer,
der spielt aber relativ viel Battlefield
oder Puppke und Battle Royale Sachen.
Selbst dort, und selbst bei mir,
ist es ja schon Abfuck gewesen.
Ich weiß noch, wir haben mal Battlefield 3 gespielt,
vor einer Weile,
sogar ich hatte Stream-Sniper.
Unglaublich!
In Battlefield 3 im Jahr 2021,
ich hatte irgendwie 250 Zuschauer, ich hatte Stream-Sniper.
Das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen.
Ein 10 Jahre altes Spiel auf Twitch, wo kaum einer zu...
Ich hatte Stream-Sniper.
Wahnsinn!
Echt krasses Zeug, ja?
Und da will ich gar nicht wissen, wie das bei denen ist.
Das heißt, der nächste Punkt ist,
du musst tatsächlich gucken,
dass du es nicht nur interessant machst für Streamer,
sondern eben auch gut spielbar machst für Streamer.
Ja.
Definitiv.
Das ist echt toll.
Ich bin ein bisschen gezwungen,
ich bin ein bisschen gezwungen,
dass ich jetzt in der nächsten Folge
noch ein bisschen mehr über die Dice-Zone
und die Dice-Extraction Zone erzählen kann.
Wie gesagt, am Anfang der Geschichte
nehmen wir alles, was wir gerade gehört haben,
nur Spekulationen, bis Dice es anders sagt.
Aber eine Sache, die eine gewisse Gerechtigkeit
zu Temporary-Haus-Findenzen bringt,
ist der Exodos-Klickfilm von Dice, der diese Woche präsentiert wurde.
Ein Satellit, der mit Daten auf dem Hourglass-Map krasst,
das in der Dose getragen werden muss,
wurde in dem Film erwähnt.
Exodos wurde zwei Jahre vor 2042 angesprochen.
Wir gucken uns das gleich an,
Hazard Zone will offer narrative content.
Overall, the datamine info
is fascinating. We've all been really
curious about this new game mode.
Hopefully DICE reveals more info soon.
Wo ist Hanna? Leute,
nicht spoilern. Ist Hanna
auch wieder dabei?
Battlefield 4 war der einzige
Singleplayer, wo ich sowas wie Motion
Sickness bekommen habe.
Weil da so viel Blur und Gewackel war,
dass ich nicht wirklich
ja, wie soll ich sagen,
genießen konnte beim Spielen.
Ich hab's glaube ich
auch nie durchgespielt. Und Hanna
war nervig.
Wobei Hanna stirbt doch am Ende, oder?
Von Battlefield 4. Ne, dann ist sie da wahrscheinlich nicht dabei.
Mal gucken, mal gucken.
Logik ist da ja eh nicht so weit her.
Ui!
Warum?
Ah.
Wie denn?
Warum sollten sie das denn machen?
Warum sollten sie irgendjemand vom
Final Game bannen?
Wieso? Die wollen doch alle Geld.
Das ist ja auch ein Problem.
Die wollen doch alle Geld.
Nein.
Übrigens, dieses Foto hier, das ist mega G-Bait.
Was er hier gemacht hat ist, es sieht aus, auf dem Thumbnail, als wäre das aus dem Playtest-Gameplay.
Dabei ist das aus dem allerersten Ankündigungstrailer mit ein bisschen Sättigungseffekte in Photoshop.
Also er hat es quasi geschafft, den Anschein zu erwecken, es wäre Leaked-Gameplay,
dabei ist es einfach nur leicht farbveränderter Trailer.
Richtig, richtig massive.
Der wollte sich aber nicht in die Brennnesseln setzen und Bilder reinmachen von dem.
Hab ich ja auch nicht gemacht.
Also ich hab mir auch gedacht, ey, ich lass es lieber mal sein, ja.
Ja, da bin ich ja immer eh gespannt.
Müssen sie ja auch.
Replaces?
Warum gibt es nicht einfach beides?
Wo ist das Problem?
Wo ist das Problem an mehr als einer Map?
Schafft es Ravensoft nicht zu handeln, mehr als eine Map oder was?
Ich meine, die tun sich ja schon schwer mit einer Map.
Ja, da bin ich übrigens auch mal gespannt.
Ich meine, Call of Duty ist in zwei Monaten oder so ja auch raus und du hast noch nichts gehört,
nichts gesehen, außer ein paar Mini-Teaser-Leaked-Dinger.
Also ich glaube, das wäre ein Fehler, Verdansk komplett zu ersetzen durch eine World War 2 Map,
weil es gibt viele Leute, die haben einfach keinen Bock auf World War 2.
Die wollen nicht...
Die wollen Warzone nicht ein Jahr auf World War 2 Maps spielen.
Die müssen beides reinmachen.
Super.
Ja.
Wenn Vanguard das später dieses Jahr macht.
Tom sagt auch, dass Vanguard...
Ich verstehe ja bis heute nicht, was die geritten hat, da jetzt wieder auf World War 2 zu machen.
Vielleicht ist die Idee aber gar nicht so schlecht, jetzt wo Battlefield am Start ist,
mit Modern Warfare, dass sie sich vielleicht nicht immer gegenseitig nachrennen,
sondern mal was anderes haben als Kontrast.
Vielleicht ist es gar nicht so blöd.
Eine neue Anti-Cheat-Solution, die integriert wird.
Äh, Rico, man weiß es noch nicht.
Man weiß es nicht.
Das Ganze heißt Vanguard, anscheinend ein Spiel im Zweiten Weltkrieg.
Aber...
Man hat weder was gesehen, noch groß was gehört bisher von.
Sehr untypisch.
Das glaubst du doch selbst nicht, dass ich da was tun werde.
Die Frage ist, ob die Devs die Warzone so explodieren können.
Cheaters und Hackers...
Ravensoft...
...kann da überhaupt nichts fixen.
Ravensoft dürfte eines der unfähigsten Läden überhaupt sein.
Aber das juckt die nicht.
Der Scheiß verkauft sie anscheinend immer noch gut.
Und solange sich das gut verkauft, who cares?
Das ist ein offizieller Trailer für ihre kommende portable PC, die Stream Deck.
Es macht ein paar ziemlich blöde Begründungen,
wie es die meiste powervolle Gaming-Handheld in der Welt sein wird.
Und zu sagen, dass es nicht falsch ist, ist wahrscheinlich...
Die meiste powervolle Gaming-Handheld in der Welt, was gibt es da als Konkurrenz?
Der DS und die Switch.
Ich meine, es ist nicht großartig kompliziert, mehr Power zu haben als die Switch.
Und wobei die Switch gar nicht mal schlecht ist.
Was? Er hat Stream Deck gesagt? Wirklich?
Das ist ein offizieller Trailer für ihre kommende portable PC, die Stream Deck.
Es macht...
Tatsächlich.
... ein paar ziemlich blöde Begründungen, wie es die meiste powervolle Gaming-Handheld in der Welt sein wird.
Das gleiche Problem. Ich habe auch.
Um ehrlich zu sein, sind sie wahrscheinlich nicht falsch.
Dritte-Party-Reviews haben letztens Zeit mit den Pre-Produktion-Modellen des Steam Deck at Valve HQ.
Und ihre Erfahrung war überwältigend positiv.
Die meisten beurteilen solidere Leistungen in Doom Eternal und anderen Spielen
bei den gewinnenden Resolutionen der Geräte.
Der Steam Deck ist aktuell zur Verfügung, als Reservationsordnungen auf Steam
und beginnt im Dezember zu verkaufen.
Nintendo hat eine permanente Entschuldigung gegen ROM-Universum erhoben.
Nintendo hat vorher ROM-Universum gesucht und wurde 2,1 Millionen Dollar in Schaden geworfen.
Ja, und die haben doch gesagt, sie bezahlen es nicht, oder?
Würdest du dir eins holen?
Pff, keine Ahnung, da habe ich mir noch nicht überlegt.
... ROMs oder playable Disk-Images von Nintendos Spielen.
Während die ROMs selbst nicht technisch illegal sind,
sind sie auch nicht in der Lage, sie zu distribuieren und Geld aus dieser Distribution zu verdienen.
Zu einem Punkt hat ROM-Universum ungefähr 30.000 Dollar pro Jahr verkauft,
um Premium-Unlimited-Accounts zu verkaufen, die die Zuschauer mit 50.000 Euro verdient haben.
Moment, 30.000 Euro im Jahr?
Das ist ja nix!
Da verdienst du ja als McDonalds-Mitarbeiter mehr.
Und dafür musst du nicht eine Webseite betreiben und von Nintendo bis ans Ende der Welt verklagt werden.
Das ist ja nix!
30.000 Euro ist ja nix!
... schneller Downloads and no limits on how many ROMs that they could download.
Oh man.
The site's owner seemed intent on continuing his operations despite the initial court loss.
This injunction prohibits him from copying, distributing, selling or playing unauthorized copies of Nintendo games.
The judge on the case ordered ROM-Universe to destroy all of the pirated Nintendo games that they hosted as well.
The social media hypes...
Wie stellt sich das der Richter vor?
Wie soll man denn ROMs destroyen?
Sind das wieder irgendwelche Richter, die keine Ahnung haben, um was es da eigentlich geht?
Wie destroyet man bitteschön ROMs?
In den Papierkorb schieben, oder wie?
... Saga, that is Abandon's Reveal, just keeps chugging on.
The game is an upcoming PlayStation 5 exclusive title and is surrounded by conspiracy theories, claiming it's secretly Hideo Kojima's next title.
The developers recently fanned the flames by releasing a teaser image with a character wearing an eyepatch like Big Boss, aka Snake, from the Metal Gear Games.
... Saga, that is Abandon's Reveal, just keeps chugging on. The game is an upcoming PlayStation 5 exclusive title and is surrounded by conspiracy theories, claiming it's secretly Hideo Kojima's next title.
They also finally launched an app for Abandon that's supposed to serve as a playable demo experience.
And unfortunately, things are getting off to a rough start.
After downloading the app, players will find a single...
Also, eins kann Kojima ja wirklich.
Und das ist so diese Schnippchen, Häppchen, Häppchenweise Werbung und Hype aufbauen für seine Games im Vorfeld.
Also das kann der echt wie kein anderer.
... teaser trailer that shows a guy walking across a wooden floor and, well, that's it.
The app will offer additional trailers and playable experiences soon, but the developers have encountered multiple delays just getting the app released.
Until they add more content to the app, it doesn't seem worth the effort to download.
Abandon doesn't yet have a release date.
Before we get to our final story this week, I just wanted to say thanks for tuning in.
We'll be back on Monday with a new video.
In the meantime, check out our social media for breaking news and updates.
PC hardware maker Gigabyte has finally responded to claims that two of their power supply models are ticking time bombs.
Hardware review outlet Gamers Nexus recently did an expose on Gigabyte's GP-P850GM and GP-750GM power supplies.
They found both models had a very high failure rate that was catastrophic, a.k.a. it could explode and kill your PC with it.
Gamers Nexus tested 10 units and 50% of them exploded.
Haben die keinerlei Qualitätskontrolle oder was?
... claims the issue is the type of testing being done to trigger the fall.
They say in the real world, no one totally saturates the power supply's capacity.
Das ist scheißegal, ob das in der real world jemand macht.
Das hat die Specs, die draufstehen, auszuhalten, plus noch ein bisschen Toleranz nach oben.
Dummes, dummes Marketing-Geschwätz, oder?
... for an extended period of time.
However, Gamers Nexus also had a power supply unit fail under 60% test load.
Gigabyte adjusted the power supply unit's failure protection threshold
and advised anyone concerned about the failure to contact their customer support.
But there's been a problem with this.
Gigabyte was recently hit with a ransomware attack
that knocked their customer support servers offline.
As of writing this, their servers have been offline for over a week
and their customer support staff are having trouble...
Haben die sich selbst gehackt, dass die nicht so viel Support-Anfragen kriegen?
... RMAs, returns and support tickets.
So the refund or replacement process might take much longer than expected.
Was ein Zufall, ja.
... and even access their support site to begin with.
And that wraps it up for this week in gaming.
As always, guys, I hope you enjoyed...
Das muss ich mir jetzt angucken, ich muss mir jetzt angucken, wie Netz, wie Netzteile explodieren.
Exploding power supplies, bam.
Auf geht's.
Wow.
Das ist, das ist wirklich schlecht, das ist wirklich schlecht.
This is called a catastrophic failure.
So is this.
And this.
Das ist schlecht, das ist ganz schlecht.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich hatte noch nie einen, bis auf eins,
einen power supply, was kaputt gegangen ist.
Ich hatte mal ein ganz billiges LC Power,
vor Jahren, das ist so'n billiges China-Ding.
... GP P750GM, or closely related, GP P850GM.
One of these catastrophically failed while under only 60% load.
And out of the 10 or so units that we bought from Newegg or acquired from viewers,
we had 2.
Newegg ist auch so'n'n richt'che Cocona-Shop-Seite, ne?
Newegg kauften die ganzen Amis immer ihre Hardware.
... several other catastrophic failures.
During the course of testing we blew three fuses from our power supply load tester
and we toasted a gigabyte RTX 3080 that was attached to one of the power supplies.
A shocking 50 percent of these failed in an explosive capacity while we were testing them.
That's some pretty good odds for fire ...
Also, ey, Leute, soll man das ganz gucken?
Ich meine, 30 Minuten ist relativ lang.
Ansonsten würde ich mal vorskippen, wo es kaputt geht.
Ja, da geht es kaputt.
Wo geht es kaputt? Ich will eigentlich nur explodierende Netzteile sehen.
Teste mit Testing Units.
... mit keinen Problemen.
Wir haben dann einen Zuschauer mit 750 in März und einen Zuschauer mit 850 mit milder Sparke und einem kleinen Puff von Schmuck getestet.
Dieser hat die gleiche Fertigungs-Lokation wie unser erster Fertigungs-Unit.
Ist da was passiert? Ich habe jetzt nichts gesehen.
Der nächste Unit, den wir getestet haben, hat gefehlt, während wir versucht haben, den exakten OPV-Trigger-Punkt zu lokalisieren.
Diesmal hat der rechte APFC-Fett mit einem milder Sparke und einem kleinen Puff von Schmuck getestet.
Dieser hat die gleiche Fertigungs-Lokation wie unser erster Fertigungs-Unit.
Also haben wir jetzt...
... an diesem Punkt...
Wow, okay, das ist wirklich nicht gut.
Wann kommt nächstes Azubi-Video?
Also als nächstes muss ich erstmal ein Stellenanzeigen-Video machen.
Dann muss ich noch ein Hetzner-Sellout-Video machen.
Das könnte ich eventuell kombinieren mit der Azubi-Story über die illegal gehosteten Sachen bei uns im Rechenzentrum.
Oh, jetzt kommt richtig MonkaSmall.
... um es zu sehen.
Wir können nicht 100% sicher sein.
... was die Verletzung ist.
Aber wir haben an diesem Punkt ziemlich gute Ideen.
Also, unser Glauben ist, dass ein Protektions-Zirkel eine Verbesserung benötigt.
Do not buy.
... und es könnte OCP sein.
Sehr gute Idee.
Do not buy, Leute.
... und es könnte OCP sein.
Da wäre ich jetzt auch drauf gekommen.
Hey, Snoop.
Du bist das beste Ding seit geschlossener Brot.
Verstehst du?
Weil du ein Löffel bist.
... und es könnte OCP sein.
Boah, ist das schlecht.
Das ist Standard-Katzenblick.
Alter, lass mich in Ruhe.
Geh mal nicht auf den Sack.
... und es könnte OCP sein.
"... massive.
Huge-Hyper-Substitution.
...
... mein neuer Smart-Home-Server-Einrichtung ...
... das wurde mir vorhin vorgeschlagen ...
... ich weiß nicht warum.
... ich habe von ihm noch nie was geguckt.
Die Bewertungen sind ...
... die Bewertungen sind wahrscheinlich richtig gut.
Wüsst ihr, was das sein wird?
Das sind die üblichen Leute, die alles, was irgendjemand zuhause baut, negativ bewerten.
... du hast so Leute.
Es reichen Leute, die danach ins Mikrocontroller-Forum gehen und Neulinge anflamen, dass sie zu dumm sind und sich hier nie wieder blicken lassen sollen.
Das Dubai-Video ist echt gut. Das geht auch nur 12 Minuten.
Ja, was machen eigentlich unsere ganzen Influencers in Dubai? Ich habe gehört, die ziehen jetzt wieder zurück.
Wenn wir das Wort Dubai hören, denken die meisten von uns an towering skyscrapers, immense Gewalt...
Was ist denn dieses Ding? Maps? Das hier? Palmen? Das meine ich.
Die einfach hier künstliche Insel ins Meer. Die hören ja gar nicht auf. Das werden ja immer mehr.
Das hört ja gar nicht auf. The World ist jetzt hier am Start. Was auch immer The World ist.
Ah, The World. Franz, Spain, Portugal?
Switzerland? Wo ist Germany? Gibt's nicht.
Germany müsste ja hier so irgendwie sein, oder? Gibt's nicht.
Franz? Franz ist dauernd.
Germany? Switzerland?
Das sind die Schweden? Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Das heißt, jede Insel ist ein Land, oder wie?
Kongo? Tja, die wollen es echt wissen.
Aber Germany gibt es nicht.
Wahrscheinlich irgendwie eins von diesen Inseln, was hier nicht belegt ist.
Naja, so. Gucken wir mal. Dubai.
Also das ist das erste, zwei Sachen, wo ich an Dubai, Dubai dran denke.
Komische deutsche Influencer, die in Dubai am Start sind und diese Insel im Meer.
Lamborghinis, 7-Star-Hotels, mit der absoluten Krise der Gesellschaft darin.
Auch die Palm Islands, die World Islands, die Burj Khalifa, die Burj Al Arab.
Futuristische Symbole von unglaublicher Gewalt.
Und so in light of all that, I'm here to make the case that Dubai, the Emirates and the Gulf countries in general are one of the worst places on the planet.
Now this is a rather bold claim, I realize, but it's one that I can substantiate fully.
So let's take a look at what's really behind this claim.
War nicht, war nicht Ziba Tower hiervon irgendwie inspiriert?
Ne, Ziba Tower in Battlefield 3 war in Teheran, oder?
Nicht in Dubai.
Behind the glitz and glamour, the true face of Dubai and the Gulf countries.
To better understand what's going on in a place like Dubai,
First, let's talk about Romania.
Oh, willkommen!
In the decades following World War II,
Doch nicht.
the capital came to face the same problem as many Eastern European capitals did at the time.
As urbanization increased and huge residential areas were built out,
the need arose for new, high-capacity public transportation.
And so Nicola Ceausescu, the dictator of Romania,
Now, history lessons.
had the order to construct a metro line.
And so the engineers created a line proposal and presented it to him.
And then Ceausescu was like, no, I will design the route personally.
And so the former shoemaker assistant, who also
Was kann schon schiefgehen?
who called himself the genius of the Carpathians, I am not making this up,
sat down and redesigned the entire metro line to have it run along the river underneath.
Yes, along.
But Nicola Ceausescu's wife, Elena Ceausescu, a former textile factory worker,
also got her fair share of planning.
Reportedly, when the planners presented the final version of the metro line to the Ceausescu couple,
Elena Ceausescu reportedly asked why the metro line...
Was genau hat das jetzt mit Dubai zu tun?
Ich bin noch nicht so ganz dahinter gekommen.
inquiring what kind of factories there are.
The planners told her there aren't any factories, but there is the Bucharest University of Economics where there are lots of students.
Hearing that, Elena Ceausescu reportedly said,
Students? They've gotten fat, they grew a belly, they should walk.
No station in Romana, let them walk.
And so, since Nicola Ceausescu added nothing to that and nobody else dared to oppose his wife,
the station was axed from the plans.
But of course, everyone outside of the dictator power couple knew that this was fucking stupid.
And so the engineers, having enough foresight, decided to build the station in secret,
banking on the fact that they would need to build a station there anyway due to future public pressure.
And they were correct.
The end result was this ridiculous and dangerously narrow station,
since the engineers couldn't build a normal station hall,
since they had to disguise their real secret project as...
Moment, Moment, Moment. Das hier ist der Bahnsteig und dahinter geht's nicht mehr weiter, oder was?
Das ist dann...
Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen klein.
... regular tunnel boring.
And so the moral of the story is, smooth brain dictator plus construction equals dumb shit.
Da ist was dran, ja.
And boy, what a perfect segway this is to the video's actual subject.
Ah, okay, das ist der Aufhänger gewesen.
The city of Dubai is a fucking joke.
It's a tasteless parody of everything wrong with modern humanity.
And so why do I say that? Let's go through it, shall we?
Ich glaube, der Typ wird kein Dubai-Influencer mehr.
Now, in my video about skyscrapers, I have already talked about the Burj Khalifa.
It's a big, dumb tower of glass and steel stuck in the middle of the desert, serving no other purpose...
Ich hab mal gehört...
... hören, sagen, dass ein Zimmer dort gar nicht so teuer ist, weil kaum jemand hin will.
Das muss wohl am Anfang so ein Riesenmagnet gewesen sein an Besucher und alles.
Und mittlerweile ist das wohl zum größten Teil total leer.
Machst du mal lauter?
Okay, ich dachte, das ist eigentlich okay.
Ich kann hier ein bisschen lauter machen.
Da müssen wir aber hier runterdrehen, sonst übersteuert's.
... und das Gebäude hat sogar sein eigenes Poem über sich selbst.
Wie ernsthaft, wie komisch kannst du das bekommen?
Ich bin die Leidenschaft der gemeinsamen Aspektionen und die ästhetische Union vieler Kulturen.
Ich simuliere Träume, störe Emotionen und...
Was zur Hölle ist das für ein Geräusch?
Oh nein, es sind die Poop-Trucks!
Ja, hast du ja gewusst, dass der Burj Khalifa nicht verbunden ist mit seinem Surre-System?
Also jeden Tag...
... eine riesige Reihe von Poop-Trucks.
Die Poop-Trucks müssen neben dem Gebäude aufhören und alle Poop-Trucks wegschneiden.
Also, die Ambition von MR und das glänzende Wunsch von Dubai...
Moment, das Ding hat keine Kanalisation?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Die müssen quasi die ganzen Hotelzimmer, die ganze Scheiße aus den Hotels...
Super, super, tolle.
Der größte Skyscraper der Welt, aber nicht ein Surre-System.
Außerdem, ich habe das vorhin in dem Skyscraper-Video gesprochen,
es gibt tatsächlich nicht viel Sinn,
wie die einzige Situation, in der es Sinn macht, ist, wenn man physisch aus dem Raum ist.
Aber vertraue mir, Dubai hat dieses Problem nicht.
Was die nächsten Anfragen bezieht...
Dubai's Palm Islands sind die OG-Symbol...
Es wäre schwer, im Sand eine Kanalisation zu bauen.
Also, wenn die so geschiss alles bauen können,
dann würde ich erwarten, so was Basic-mäßiges wie eine Kanalisation bekommt man da auch hin.
Der erste, die Palm Jumeirah, hat 2001 angefangen,
wenn du das glaubst.
Wenn du Google Satellite-Images anschaust, ist es noch nicht fertig.
Es wird immer noch ausgebaut.
Und nur für gute...
Woher haben die eigentlich das Geld?
Ich meine...
So groß sind die doch gar nicht, oder?
Alles Öl.
Ja, das dachte ich mir, aber so groß sind die doch gar nicht.
Also, die haben im Prinzip, haben die Dubai, und drum herum ist alles Öl, oder was?
Let's take a look at what they actually built here.
I mean, these things do look nice from space,
but what are they really, from up close and personal?
Well, the stem is an 8-lane urban freeway,
and the leaves are just individual suburban streets.
Oh, and there's also a monorail in the middle.
Oh, and between THE POINT and Nakheel Mall, there are no stations.
So then, how do people living on the leaves get on this thing?
Well, it's a rhetorical question, of course.
Just like the real suburbs in America, this thing was built around cars.
And the second Palm, the Jebel Ali, will be more the same.
And then there are the World Islands, of course,
which are just a complex of tiny islands for the ultra-rich and their villas.
And, oh my god, this looks outright post-apocalyptic, Jesus Christ.
Oh, and there's a third Palm under construction, if the two weren't enough.
Oh, and by the way, the sand they use for the palms is not desert sand.
They can't use it, because the grains are too big.
Instead, they have to get the sand from the seafloor.
And they achieve this by sucking it up with these big tanker ships.
And also annihilating acres of marine life in the process.
Oh, and by the way, these Palm Islands were built on top of natural coral reefs,
which they just ended up basically burying.
Oh, and according to NASA...
Ja, ich mein, YOLO, who cares, Umwelt.
Das haben wir ja schon gewohnt.
All these islands are sinking at a rate of five millimeters per year.
And by the way, have you heard about this thing called the rising sea levels?
According to the Environment Agency Abu Dhabi, under the most severe climate change scenario,
nearly all of Dubai, including the Palm Islands, would be underwater.
Alright, so let me get this straight.
You had all the money and power in the world to create anything.
And you have paid money to annihilate a coral reef to build a sinking suburb on top of it.
Perhaps I treated you too harshly.
And here's the kicker about these islands.
That's right, I'm still not done.
Why build them on the sea to begin with?
I mean, you have the desert.
You have all the space you will ever need.
So why not just build the palms inverted into the land?
You know, having the actual body of the palm not out of sand, but out of water.
It would look just as impressive from space and it wouldn't even demolish all the aquatic life.
Hang on a second, they did do something like this already.
Just below the palm tree.
And oh no, these are American-style suburbs.
Oh man.
Believe it, they took the worst urbanism practices from the US and they implemented it one to one.
It looks like Factorio.
I don't know exactly what it is, but it looks like Factorio.
And we actually have all the circles of urbanism hell in here.
Copy-paste housing, cul-de-sacs, giant highways coming through the area, no public transportation.
A 12-lane arterial road.
Jesus Christ.
They want to know.
Can women drive a car in Dubai?
I read Saudi Arabia.
Was da wohl für einen großen Aufschrei gesorgt hat.
And so this will be our segue to
Dubai's urbanism in general is just complete bonkers.
It's kind of its own little bubble, really.
A strange little rich people's dystopia in the desert.
Take a look at this arrangement.
Two sections of skyscrapers separated by a 20-something lane freeway and behind it a bunch of cul-de-sac suburbs and golf courses.
Is this strange?
Natürlich.
Man ist schön im grünen Golfspielen.
A mixture between Futurama and evil Los Angeles.
And this just makes me feel so frustrated because all that money and all that power, they could have done so much more and so much better than this.
The way I understand it, the main motive behind building all this flashy stuff was to try and increase tourism, to help the Emirates economy transition away from oil revenues.
Which is, you know, fair enough.
But then why not build something truly unique?
Something that isn't just a big dumb tower of glass and steel.
Or a couple dozen suburban streets on sinking sandbanks.
Or gigantic malls or golf courses.
Imagine a city with full-on historic Arabic golden age architecture with modern elements.
Okay, this is concept art from Diablo 3, but you get the idea.
I have seen skyscrapers, malls, suburbs, urban freeways or golf courses before.
What I haven't seen is a historical or at least historicist Arab city.
That would be a great way of spending all those petrol dollars.
Or at least a better way, I would say.
And that might even attract a more quality crowd instead of the oligarchic...
Gibt es irgendwelche Hochrechnungen oder so, wie lange das Öl da noch reicht?
Ich meine, das hängt ja von zwei Sachen ab.
Also wenn man davon ausgeht, also ich phantasier mir das jetzt mal zusammen, keine Ahnung, ob das stimmt.
Aber einmal, ob die Leute weiterhin überhaupt so viel Öl haben wollen von denen, dann ist es irgendwann vielleicht leer.
Oder aber die Welt geht jetzt die nächsten Jahrzehnte mehr weg von Erdöl, dann wird es natürlich für die auch problematischer.
Circa 60 bis 100 Jahre, okay.
... von Babys and nowhere-ish idiots.
Okay, that's a bit unfair, but Dubai right now is not exactly a haven of intellectualism, so to speak.
By the way, did you know that only 10% of the Emirates population is actually Emirati?
The other 90% being immigrants and expats.
Well, actually they are all immigrants, it's just that white people came up with...
Expats? Sind das nicht die aus Battlefield 2042?
... word expat, so they don't have to call themselves immigrants abroad, because that word is reserved for brown people.
And this right here is my biggest problem with Dubai, the Emirates and the Gulf states in general.
All that luxury, wealth and opulence you see all around you in Dubai rests on a mountain of human tragedies.
Poor people from third world countries such as India, Pakistan and Bangladesh are lured in by work agencies, promising high wages and stable income.
Die verdienen wahrscheinlich fast nichts.
People take loans from friends and family so they can cover the costs of their travel and work visa, usually more than $2000, despite Emirati law requiring the companies to pay for those.
Upon arrival, workers' passports are often confiscated, essentially trapping them instead.
So nach dem Motto, ihr könnt nicht mal mehr abhauen, selbst wenn ihr wollt.
Workers are forced to work up to 12-hour shifts, up to 7 days a week, for $175 per month on average.
Das ist ja schlimmer als der indische Microsoft Support.
Wager years are common, many workers not receiving money for months on end.
To quote from a Human Rights Watch report,
The impact on workers whose wages are withheld for even one month is very serious.
They immediately fall into arrears on the death day of recruiting agencies in their home countries.
They incur additional interest, and they are unable to send money home for their families who depend on their income earning in the Emirates.
In some cases, the non-payment of wages means that workers do not have money to buy food or basic goods and end up borrowing money just to survive.
Ja, und wenn sie ihre Pässe einziehen, dann können die nicht mehr abhauen.
Aber das juckt die wahrscheinlich in Dubai wenig.
The Covid epidemic only made things worse.
That, and the oil price crashing, left many workers jobless.
Consequently, many were abandoned by their former employers.
They now spend their days in half-abandoned worker camps on the outskirts of the city.
Only volunteers and their food donations standing between them and starvation.
A Guardian article quotes a construction worker called Hassan.
He says, guests on and off visit and give something, but when nobody comes, we have to starve.
We have nothing.
Also sprich, die haben jetzt die Arbeiter geholt,
und jetzt gibt's noch nicht mal Geld und noch nicht mal Arbeit, oder wie?
Und abhauen können sie auch nicht.
Ja, das ist ja geil.
Da haben sich ja was geiles ausgedacht.
Ah, excellent, erst mal ein paar goldene Porsche.
Goldene Por...
Ja.
Hauptsache Simon Desio kann ein Video machen, wo er irgendwie goldene Porsche zeigt oder sowas.
pop
Ja das ist halt so der typische Influencer-Post.
This and the previously mentioned issues, but especially this, is why I hate the Emirates and especially fucking hate Dubai.
The city of Dubai is a fucking joke, one that's unusually cruel.
It's a twisted parody of everything wrong with modern humanity.
I'll leave you with a poem from Berthold Brecht, written in 1935, titled...
Moment, von Berthold Brecht, von wem?
...with a poem from Berthold Brecht...
Oh, ey, ey, die Aussprache ist gar nicht mal so schlecht.
1935...
Ah, okay, naja, okay.
Ja, kann ich nachvollziehen, klingt schlüssig, was er sagt.
Komm, die Aussprache war gar nicht so schlecht für jemand, der noch nie Berthold Brecht ausgesprochen hat.
War es natürlich auch so, okay.
Kann man sich jetzt nicht beschweren.
So, also.
Battlefield 6 Ultra liegt.
Ich mach das jetzt nicht auf.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das zeigen darf.
Ja, ja.
Ja, weißt du ja nie, was da abgeht.
Ach, stimmt, wir wollen den Battlefield-Shortfilm gucken, genau.
Äh, den hier.
Ich bin mal echt gespannt.
Ich bin echt gespannt, ob der was taugt.
Also, ich hab den noch nicht geguckt und ich fand die Overwatch-Storyfilme immer nice.
Mal gucken, ob das ähnlich ist.
Also, wenn ich mal davor was raten müsste...
...würde ich sagen...
...wenn ich sagen, wann die Beta startet.
Äh, ich hab vergessen.
Ich hab's vergessen.
Es gab ein paar geleakte Daten.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es offiziell schon was gibt.
Nein, hab ich noch nicht gesehen.
Ähm.
Also, wenn ich jetzt davor was raten müsste, dann ist es...
Also, was ich an den Overwatch-Filmen ganz cool fand, ist...
...dass das nicht so ernst genommen war.
Und ich fänd es ja cool, wenn die Story ein bisschen so...
...so, so, so light-hearted bleibt.
Ja, glaub ich aber nicht.
Die werden es wahrscheinlich voll auf...
...voll auf Ernst und Bedeutung machen.
Mal schauen.
Also, gucken wir uns mal an.
Battlefield 2042 Exodus.
Also, Leute, wer nicht alt genug ist, jetzt ausschalten.
Ist laut genug?
Ich glaub, das ist okay.
Das wird bestimmt gleich lauter.
Hab ich Untertitel an?
Ah.
Ich lass mal Untertitel an.
Alter, gehst du da unten weg?
Komisches...
...komisches Ladeding aus dem Browser.
Geh weg.
Oh.
Wie hieß das Ding nochmal?
Das ist...
Das ist aus der Battle...
Das ist aus dem Battlefield 3 Singleplayer.
Das ist das Spielzeug von...
...von, ähm...
...von dem Sohn des Panzerfahrers.
Aus dem...
...aus der Battlefield 3 Singleplayer.
Aus der Battlefield 3 Singleplayer-Kampagne.
Spoiler!
Da wird gestelzt.
So, bis ich leise, oder?
Warte mal, ich mach mal kurz lauser.
Leider ist es immer schwierig.
Okay, so ist gut.
So ist gut.
Wow.
Jetzt ist es wieder zu laut.
MonkaS.
Ich mein...
Okay, ich sag jetzt nix, aber...
Warum schleicht man...
...und dann fährt man mit so nem Jetski rum?
Ist nicht sonderlich stealthy, oder?
Anzeige ist raus.
Rekt.
Hä?
Kennt man den?
Das ist Irish, genau.
Das haben wir ja vorher schon gesehen.
Kennt man den Typen?
Beide aus Battle...
Moment, Moment.
Wie heißt der Dude?
Wie heißt... Wie heißt der Dude?
Pekowski.
Pekau... Hab ich...
Der hier ist aus Battlefield 4?
Tatsächlich.
Tatsächlich!
Lull.
Kann ich mich nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Horst.
Ich kann mich nur an Irish und Hannah erinnern in Battlefield 4.
Ich... Pepega.
You traitor.
How much did the Notepads pay you to fuck over your home country?
My loyalty is with the refugees on this boat.
That includes you now.
Irish.
Stimmt.
Ich glaube...
Hier hieß der Typ nicht Racker, den man gespielt hat in Battlefield 4?
Blackburn hieß mal in Battlefield 3.
Ich glaube, Racker hieß mal in Battlefield 4.
I think you better take a look at something.
Listen.
If you give Oz that case,
that fucking terrorist will start World War 3.
That's what they always say, Pac.
Dritte Welt kriegt mal wieder was ganz Neues.
I need that shit. I want to.
Jetzt fehlt bloß noch Russland vs. US.
Dann hätten wir alle Battlefield-Story-Glischees.
Das ist kein Trailer, das ist irgendwie ein Kurzfilm für die Battlefield 2042-Story.
Hört sich an wie ich.
Ah, Russland, natürlich.
Russland vs. US, was sonst?
Immer der gleiche Schild, Alter.
Hier fällt wirklich nichts mehr ein.
Wir kommen uns, Alter.
Wir haben Zivilisten an Bord, wir haben nicht genug Macht, ich glaube nicht, dass wir eine Wahl haben.
Hört sich direkt an den Sturm an.
Das ist in Kategorie 5, Sir.
Ah, das ist die Vorteilung von der Home-Field.
Scheiße, ich denke, sie haben die Verhandlungen abgeschlossen.
Du hast das Auto falsch, ich habe das Boot nicht mitgebracht.
Was ist da los?
Die Stürme sind verdammt kaputt!
Erstmal Wong-Man alles wegmachen.
Mein Cooling-Szenier ist es ja schon.
Ah, guck mal, da ist ein Heli.
Zufälligerweise liegt er an den RPG.
Da haben wir mal Glück gehabt.
Und jetzt 360.
Wie? Nicht?
Das ist aber unrealistisch.
Also ich hätte jetzt eigentlich einen 360-RPG-Heli-Sniper erwartet.
Ja, er klang ja von Anfang an...
What the fuck macht sein Sohn jetzt random da?
Wie kommt der da hin?
Okay, das ist jetzt Grund dafür, dass der die jetzt richtig fertig macht.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, die bringen doch keine Kette.
Die nehmen die Kinder um.
Weggesniped.
Wir sind richtig geil gestelzt mit der Sniper,
aber dann im offenen Rumpf gestanden und sich vom Heli wegbashen lassen.
Und jetzt 360-RPG, jawoll.
So muss das sein.
Der Dino ist aus Battlefield 3.
Moment, Moment.
Das Kind nennt seinen Vater Irish?
Ernsthaft?
Ja, ist klar.
Ich bin kurz davor erschossen zu werden und mein Vater ist am starten.
Ich sage nicht Papa, sondern ich sage Irish.
Genau, alles klar.
Zumal Irish doch sein Codename ist.
Der Typ heißt doch gar nicht so.
Oder?
Hätte ich jetzt erwartet.
Ah, das ist der Onkel.
Siehste mal.
Alles mitgekriegt.
Message sent.
Das erinnert mich voll an den ersten...
Wir müssen diese Kriege beenden.
Wir müssen hinter dieser Situation hinschauen.
presenter
eine Anrufe an jeder Not-Ь ist die Hürde
36 Stunden bei z cucumber
Wir müssen vorbeibringen unserer Bremse
Okay, geht, geht, geht.
Geht, geht
durchaus durch
Aber gespannt was es sonst noch für Kurzfilme geben wird.
Sonderlich viel von der Story hat man nicht mitbekommen,
ähm...
dieses Message sent das hat mich ein bisschen an den ersten Overwatch Kurzfilm erinnert,
falls ihn jemand gesehen hat, wo dann Winston am Ende auch auf diesen Overwatch-Call-Knopf drückt.
Das war vom Ende natürlich ein komplett anderer Style.
Ja, okay.
Tja, mal schauen.
Man hat jetzt raus...
Was haben wir denn storytechnisch erfahren?
Iris ist jetzt irgendwie so Art Söldner oder sowas?
Stellst da rum und basht Leute.
Mehr habe ich da jetzt nicht draus verstanden.
Ach ja, ähm, äh...
Russen vs. Amis, natürlich.
Wer hätte auch was anderes erwartet in Battlefield?
Selbstverständlich.
Ansonsten bin ich eigentlich genauso schlau.
Und sie treffen sich in Doha.
Genau.
Ansonsten bin ich genauso schlau wie vorher.
Die NoPets sind keine Amis.
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber anscheinend ist es ja trotzdem wieder mit zwei Fraktionen und du kämpfst halt für die eine oder für die andere.
Was erzählst du?
Was erzählen sie uns ansonsten mit Terroristen und Russen und sonst was?
NoPets sind ja so Art Söldner, die dann für wen auch immer am Start sind.
Max, was machst du nochmal immer gegen diese Persopflicht bei U18-Filmen?
Ganz einfach.
Hier.
So sieht das normalerweise aus.
Und das geht nicht.
Du löscht das hier und sagst embed.
Und dann geht's.
You check.
Sixhead.
Geht nicht immer.
Ja, das ist korrekt.
Das geht nicht immer.
Ich weiß nicht, wann es geht und wann es nicht geht.
Ich vermute, das hängt mit dem Video-Encoding zusammen.
Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Geht nicht mehr.
Wie gesagt, bei manchen Videos geht's, bei manchen geht's nicht.
Beim Battlefield-Gameplay-Trailer geht es zum Beispiel nicht.
Nein, YouTube-DL geht auch nicht.
YouTube-DL kann seit einer Woche oder so auch keine...
Altersgeschütz mehr runterladen.
Das kann sein.
Weiß nicht.
Ach, YouTube-DLP kann das.
Okay.
Mit Additional Features.
Das muss ich mir später mal angucken.
Exquisite Chat.
Ist das nicht verboten?
Ich bin übrigens echt...
...bisschen stinkig, dass ich den Termin verpasst habe.
Ich muss Ende des Jahres meinen Personalausweis verlängern lassen.
Und da muss ich jetzt Fingerabdrücke abgeben.
Ich will eigentlich keine Fingerabdrücke abgeben.
Beim Reisepass muss man es, glaube ich, schon machen.
Aber ich will meine Fingerabdrücke nicht irgendwie in der Cloud speichern lassen.
Das nervt mich richtig.
Aber es geht wohl nicht anders.
Also man kann keinen Ausweis mehr jetzt machen ohne Fingerabdrücke.
Ja, ja, ich weiß.
Im Reisepass sind die schon länger drin.
Aber das ist mir doch egal.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Das ist nicht optional.
Das ist Pflicht seit August.
Seit August ist das Pflicht.
Ja, da habe ich...
...ehrlich gesagt gar keinen Bock drauf.
So, mein neuer Smart Home Server.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich kenne ihn nicht.
Das Video wurde mir vorhin empfohlen.
Gucken wir uns das mal an.
Neuer Smart Home Server.
So, und ich gehe davon aus, dass die Negativ-Dislikes Leute sind, die prinzipiell alles disliken, was Leute daheim bauen.
Du hast so Leute...
Das sehe ich auch bei meinen Serverraum-Videos und sonst wie.
Da hast du immer Leute, die in den Kommentaren schreiben.
Haha, Max, lass das das nächste Mal den Profi machen.
Dislike.
So Leute hast du immer, die alles schlecht finden, wenn sie es nicht selbst gemacht haben.
Und selbst dann, wenn sie es selbst gemacht hätten und man würde es ihnen zeigen, würden sie es auch schlecht finden, wenn sie nicht wüssten, dass es von ihnen ist.
Oder bevor du zum Ausweis machen gehst, Kleber auf die Finger schmieren.
Kann man das irgendwie faken? Geht das?
Ist das erlaubt?
Okay.
Hey Leute und herzlich willkommen zu diesem neuen Video.
Heute ist es soweit.
Mein Server-Rack wird mal ein bisschen geupgradet.
So ist gut.
Und was genau passiert nach dem Intro.
Viel Spaß.
Server-Rack-Update.
Home-Assistent.
Poggers.
Plex ist auch so ein Ding.
Ich verstehe nicht die Anwendungszweck von einem Plex-Server.
Also ich weiß, was man damit macht.
Man streamt damit Filme.
Aber warum?
Warum macht man das?
Das ist doch eigentlich nur für Leute, die sich die Sachen über Torrent oder Usenet oder sonst was ziehen.
Weil wenn ich Netflix oder Amazon oder sonst was habe, dann gucke ich das direkt über die App von denen.
Und alles andere.
Also Plex ist doch eigentlich nur für Leute, die irgendwie eine große, sagen wir mal, Sicherheitskopien-Bibliothek haben, oder?
Aber ich lade mir gar keine Filme mehr runter.
Und speichere auch keine Filme mehr unten.
Warum sollte ich denn terabyteweise für irgendwelche Filme offline haben, wenn ich die einfach online streamen kann?
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Gibt halt so Qualitäts-Fetischisten.
Also die meisten neuen Amazon-Sachen kriegst du komplett in 4K.
Sogar teilweise mit HDR über Amazon.
Egal.
Also ich habe es für mich zumindest noch nicht so genau verstanden, wozu man das braucht.
Und ich möchte nicht, dass es bei meinem Smartphone...
Frist.
Irgendwann mal Verzögerungen gibt, einfach aus dem Grund, dass da gerade jemand über meinen Plex-Server sich Serien anschaut.
Aus diesem Grund und natürlich auch, da ich eine Serie gemacht habe, wie ihr Home Assistant auf einem Raspberry Pi installieren könnt,
Link übrigens unten in der Videobeschreibung, werde ich in diesem Video Home Assistant komplett auf einem Raspberry Pi aufsetzen,
das Ganze in meinen Server-Rack integrieren und dabei das Ganze auch nochmal aufsetzen.
Ich will keine Home Assistant installieren.
Macht er auch gar nicht.
Wir kriegen keine Home Assistant-Installation gezeigt, weil das wäre mega langweilig.
Ausräumen.
Habe ich schon viel zu oft gemacht.
So, ich habe jetzt angefangen.
BX-Racer-Stuhl erst mal am Start.
Denn ich werde nicht nur Home Assistant darauf installieren, sondern gleichzeitig das ganze System auch noch auf einer SSD aufbauen.
Ja.
Denn ich möchte...
Ist auch das einzig Sinnvolle.
Micro-SD und Home Assistant ist lahm as fuck.
Das Ganze natürlich möglichst 24-7 laufen lassen können, ohne dass irgendwann meine SD-Karte abschmiert.
Ja.
Mittlerweile ist es also soweit.
Home Assistant ist installiert.
Ist das so eine 1&1-Fritz-Box?
Ja.
Das ist so eine 1&1-Fritz-Box gebrandet von Unity Media, ist das so, oder?
SSD ist aufgesetzt, auch wenn das Ganze super stressig war, da SSDs mit dem Raspberry Pi nicht zu 100% funktionieren, wenn man nicht die richtigen SSD-Adapter besitzt.
Und Home Assistant superweist, also nicht das Betriebssystem, sondern wenn man ein ganz normales Linux-Betriebssystem nimmt und darauf Home Assistant installiert...
Habe ich nicht mehr.
...dass ich auch mit einer SSD nicht unterstütze.
Somit habe ich jetzt Home Assistant OS, also das Betriebssystem, auf einer SSD installiert und zum Laufen bekommen.
Um den USB-Adapter...
Das ist auch die beste Variante, das habe ich auch mittlerweile, aber ich habe es in der 4M laufen.
Also den Konbi-Stick für ZigBee zum Laufen zu bekommen, muss ich noch einen USB-Verlängerungsstecker verwenden, da ansonsten dieser Stick einfach nicht funktioniert hat.
Ja, das ist übrigens ein bekanntes Problem.
Die ZigBee-Sticks haben, weil die glaube ich auch 2,4 Gigahertz sind oder sowas, die haben echt Probleme, wenn die zu nah am Rechner dran sind.
Den ZigBee-Stick, wenn man den über einen USB-Verlängerungskabel nimmt...
...und ein bisschen nebendran legt, dann funktioniert es, aber direkt ans Gehäuse gestöpselt funktioniert es oftmals nicht.
Das Problem hatte ich auch.
Ich kann meine Thread-Free-Bridge und meine Philips Hue-Bridge endlich vom Strom nehmen, denn jetzt kann ich alle Geräte direkt über den Konbi-Stick ansprechen.
Was jetzt noch überbleibt, ist mein Server-Rack einzuräumen, umzubauen und dann den Raspberry Pi auch noch...
Ja, zeigt mal her, Server-Rack.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, was hat er da für ein Gehäuse gehabt am Start?
Ah, das ist irgendein fettes...
...mit...
...mit, äh, äh, äh, Hotswap-Dingern?
Kennt man da irgendwas?
Nicht wirklich.
Riss zumindest viel Strom.
Warum legt er den Raspberry Pi nicht einfach in die 4HE-Kiste rein?
Dann sieht's von außen cooler aus und er spart trotzdem Strom.
Fände ich, das wäre eine gute Idee.
Ich hackere mein Getränk hier nebendran.
So, hier oben hat er seinen Nass drinstehen, dann kommt irgendwie ein neuer.
Was ist denn das?
HP?
Pro?
Was ist das?
Pro-Safe?
Netgear, oder?
Switch.
Aber zumindest ordentlich verkabelt.
Sieht besser aus als bei mir.
So, und dann möchte ich auch direkt die Gelegenheit nutzen und euch mal eine aktualisierte Tour durch meinen Server-Rack geben.
Ah, zeigt der USV oben am Start?
Hier steht mein Backup-Server.
Dieser sichert alle Daten von meinem Haupt-Server und mir ist mit einer 10TB-Festplatte bestückt.
Daneben haben wir einen Homematic-Access-Point.
Der steht hier einfach nur rum, weil ich aktuell keine Homematic-Geräte angeschlossen habe.
Und falls ich das irgendwann wieder anschließen möchte...
Ah, Homematic ist ja auch Paints-Champ.
...wieder anschließen möchte, liegt er hier.
USV?
Daneben haben wir eine USV, die das Rack im Zweifel noch mit Strom versorgen kann.
Damit hatte ich auch meine Probleme.
Mittlerweile ist meine USV nicht mehr in Betrieb.
Meine USV war ja der Meinung, selbst wenn der Strom da ist, aber die Batterie kaputt, das ganze Rack auszuschalten.
Also, nope.
...irgendein Stromausfall sein sollte.
Darunter mein Switch, der aktuell nicht voll bestückt ist, sondern eben nur hier der erste Teil.
Da ich hier aber einige neue Geräte anschließe, habe ich eben hier noch ein paar Spare-Ports frei.
Direkt unter den Netzwerkkabeln versteckt sich mein Raspberry Pi 4.
Das ist jetzt der neue Smart Home Core, sag ich mal.
Wie hat er denn gemountet?
...ist der in natürlich Netzwerk.
Wie hat er... Ah, das ist was 3D-drucktes, guck mal.
3D-gedrucktes Pi-Rack-Mount.
Das finde ich cool.
Moment, das muss ich mal kurz... da muss ich mal kurz checken.
Thingiverse.
Pi-Rack.
Tatsächlich.
Guck mal hier.
Wobei mich so ein Single-Mount-Ding auch...
Hier?
Ne, das ist ein Fertiger.
Oder ist das auch 3D-druckt hier?
Das sieht nicht 3D-druckt aus.
Doch, das ist auch 3D-druckt.
Cool.
Hast du das nicht schon mal gesucht?
Doch, das kommt mir bekannt vor.
Habe ich aber noch nicht gemacht.
Nice, ich glaube, sowas drucke ich mir später mal aus.
Oder das da.
Ist natürlich auch nice.
Wie druckt man das aus?
Nicht im Ganzen, ne?
Das druckt man...
Ah, einzeln.
Weil so viele Raspberry-Pies habe ich gar nicht.
Ich habe im Serverraum einen stehen und der ist für den Drucker.
Aber das finde ich schon mal schön gemacht.
Per USB ist die SSD angeschlossen.
Das ist das Kabel hier.
Und hier oben seht ihr...
Es wackelt aber ein bisschen, ne?
Und hier rechts daneben ist das USB-Verlängerungskabel,
welches einmal nach hier oben geht.
Und hier aktuell noch...
ZigBee-Stick, Konbi.
Der Konbi-Stick, der dann die ganze Geräte steuern kann.
Das ist der Neue.
Ich glaube, sogar der Zweier ist das.
Hier haben wir dann noch einmal USB-C.
Damit wird der Raspberry-Pi...
Jetzt Strom versorgt.
Das Ganze befindet sich in einem selbst gedruckten Gehäuse.
Link dazu packe ich euch in die Beschreibung,
wenn ihr euch das selber mal auf...
Das ist das, wo dann manche Leute für negative Kommentare geben.
Du hast auf YouTube eh so viele überhebliche Kommentarschreiber.
So nach dem Motto,
Haha, Max, lass das mal ein Profi machen.
Oder bei ihm schreibt dann jemand in die Kommentare,
Dislike, wärst du mal mein Azubi,
der hätte ich dich damit durchfallen lassen.
Haha.
Oder irgendwie sowas.
Es ist unglaublich,
wie viele Vollspasten es auf YouTube gibt.
...drucken möchtet.
Dann haben wir hier ein kleines...
Also, wie gesagt,
ich sage das jetzt explizit nicht.
Ja, ich finde das gut, wie er das gemacht hat.
...Platz für Ausbau.
Und darunter dann meinen aktuellen Server.
Das ist ein NAS,
wo aber auch eben einige Services drauflaufen.
Eine 4HE-Kiste, so muss das sein.
... und noch ein paar andere Dienste.
Wenn der Kram nicht so stromfressend wäre,
hätte ich meine 4HE-Kiste auch noch im Einsatz.
Vorher mein Home Assistant drauf,
was ich jetzt eben auf den Raspberry Pi migriert habe.
An Festplatten habe ich hier zwei 10-TB-Festplatten,
zwei SSDs und eine 4-TB-Festplatte für Filme und Serien
und auch noch ein paar Backups von meinen PCs.
Das Ganze ist auf Schienen.
Die meisten sizen ihren Home...
Das stimmt.
Ich habe ja auch damals richtig fettes Ding gebaut,
als ich hier den Raum zuerst ausgestattet habe.
Und bis ich jetzt zum Schluss gekommen bin,
total oversized,
jetzt bin ich bei einem Low-Power-Intel-Quad-Core,
also bei so einem 8-Watt-Core,
8-Watt-Idle-Ding
und hat kaum Schnittstellen PCI-Express,
aber reicht für das, was ich machen will
und braucht irgendwie ein Drittel an Strom.
Jetzt ist es direkt wie früher.
Xerox Xeno, Dankeschön.
24 Monate Subscription hier.
Hyper Subscriptions hier.
... wenn ich mal daran arbeiten möchte.
Und hier unten drunter ist ein, ich sag mal, Fehlkauf von mir.
Das ist ein Switch, den ich vorher verwendet habe.
Auch in einem...
Leider gibt es keine Single-Board-Computer
mit mehr als einem SATA-Pod.
Ja, wie gesagt, du kriegst,
also die Low-Power-Intel-X86-Kisten
kriegst du mit mehreren SATA-Ports
und die brauchen auch nicht wirklich viel mehr
als ein Raspberry Pi 4.
... mit 48 Ports.
Eitel, eitel.
Allerdings ist der ultra laut
und deswegen für meine Zwecke eigentlich nicht geeignet.
Denn wenn ich hier im Normalfall die Türe schließe,
ist es von der Lautstärke her eigentlich relativ leise.
Man hört die Lüfter hier leicht suchen,
aber es ist eben kein störendes Geräusch.
Wohingegen dieser Switch...
Ich glaube,
dieses Rack, das ist das,
was ich mir ursprünglich auch mal bestellen wollte,
was UPS mit zerbrochenem Glas geliefert hat.
Wo ich dann extra noch diesen
PayPal-Käufer-Klärungs-Service benutzen musste,
wo sich der Shop auf am letzten Tag gemeldet hat
und hat gemeint,
zurückschicken ist zu teuer,
behalt's einfach.
Dann hatte ich irgendwie jetzt ein Jahr
in meiner Garage ein Rack rumstehen
mit kaputtem Glas.
... eben einfach viel zu laut war.
So, und das war's von meiner kleinen Tour
und meinem Umbau mit dem Raspberry Pi.
Ich hoffe, es konnte einigen von euch
helfen, wenn ihr mal...
Hat er doch echt gut gemacht.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was man da jetzt negativ bewerten sollte.
Gucken wir uns mal die Eu-Comments an.
Brauchst du die Tür unbedingt?
Nö.
Aber mein jetziges Rack gefällt mir eh besser, weil es offen ist.
Ich mein, ich hab ja den Vorteil
von...
Ich hab ja den Vorteil, dass ich
einen eigenen Raum habe.
Ich hab ja den Vorteil, dass ich einen eigenen Raum habe.
Und da ist so ein Rack, was offen ist,
eigentlich
viel, viel praktischer.
Da kommt man nämlich
wenigstens überall dran
von der Seite.
Ja, also das verstehe ich nicht, warum die hier großartig
gedisliked haben, aber es ist ein gutes Video von ihm.
Mal gucken, mal gucken, was die Leute wieder flamen.
Richtig, gut, gutes Video.
Was ist das für ein Typ
wieder? Alter!
Es geht so viel...
Was für ein Vogel, ja.
Der Typ zeigt sein...
Server-Rack.
Wo ist das Problem? Das muss doch für den gar nicht...
Du zeigst da irgendwas, was für niemanden lustig ist.
Der Switch ist zu laut.
Fragezeichen, Fragezeichen, Fragezeichen, Fragezeichen, Fragezeichen, Fragezeichen.
Bitte nicht die nächste Woche wieder.
Hä? Alter, warum schreibt man solche Comments?
Sonst geht's dir aber gut, ne?
Wenn dir das Video nicht passt, bitte...
Ja, korrekt.
Keine Kritik. Das ist doch keine Kritik.
Das ist einfach sinnloses Gebäsche.
Das ist einfach sinnloses, sinnloses, sinnloses Gebäsche.
Meine Kritik wäre gewesen, wenn er zum Beispiel...
Wenn er zum Beispiel geschrieben hätte, du hättest uns ja auch mal die...
Thingiverse-Sachen verlinken können, dass man selbst ausdrucken kann oder so.
Okay.
Das ist zum Beispiel sinnvolle Kritik.
Jetzt weiß der wenigstens auch, wo das Problem ist.
Okay, das finde ich in Ordnung.
Das finde ich ja in Ordnung.
Der schreibt wenigstens, was er für ein Problem hat.
Okay, das kann ich jetzt nachvollziehen.
Lavas, Lavalampen...
Da kann das Video nicht aufmachen.
Das packt.
Diablo 4, Chefentwickler und mehr von Blizzard.
Leute, ich habe jetzt tatsächlich die Diablo Resurrected, oder wie das Ding genau heißt, Alpha gespielt, Beta-Test gespielt.
Ich habe ja gesagt auf Twitter, ich kaufe mir das nicht, aber ich habe durch, ähm, wie heißt das, Drops, den Kram bekommen.
Das erste, was ich hatte, ist 9 Schar gelevelt auf 6, Server gecrashed, Scheiß, wieder 1.
Aber ansonsten muss ich sagen, ist echt ganz gut umgesetzt bis jetzt.
Twitch-Drops, ja.
Du musst 2,5 Stunden Diablo Resurrected gucken, dann kriegst du den Kram als Drop.
Geht das noch? Wahrscheinlich.
Drops.
Twitch.
Du musst aber dein Account verknüpfen, dass das geht.
Ja.
Oh.
Nein.
Ist nicht mehr, ist nicht mehr aktiv.
Okay, Quade.
Na gut.
So, schauen wir mal.
Habe ich die Musik viel zu laut gehabt.
Schauen wir mal, ähm.
Eigentlich interessiert mich nichts davon.
RIP GameStar.
So, was haben wir ansonsten?
Battlefield 3 Top Plays.
Ja, das muss mal wieder sein.
Log Picking Lawyer.
Twitch Meta.
Browser DevTools.
Das ist hier Big Brain Content wieder.
Leute, wir gucken jetzt.
Wir gucken jetzt die DevTools.
9 Minuten 95.
Danach gucken wir.
Wir gucken Battlefield 3 und dann muss ich mal Hippo-Poo-Poo machen.
Scammers.
Skippt keine Scammer im Internet.
Fake News.
... off their massive bank account balances while they try to sell you a course on how you can get...
Ich habe noch nie einen Scammer im Internet gesehen.
... but there's actually an easier way to...
Die ganzen indischen Microsoft-Mitarbeiter sind auch komplett legit.
... your bank account.
Open up the browser console with Control-Shift-J.
Then execute this line of code to turn the document's design mode on.
We can now modify any text in the webpage itself.
Like the bank account balance.
As developers, we tend to take a lot of technologies for granted.
One of which is the web browser.
Not only is it one of the most important technologies for all of humanity,
but modern browsers contain all kinds of awesome developer tools that were unimaginable 10 years ago.
In today's video, we'll look at a ton of features and tricks in your browser's DevTools
that you probably didn't know exist and will make your life much easier as a web developer.
First, like and subscribe to keep this content coming.
Natürlich, was sonst?
Was sonst?
Then add your own pro tip to the comments.
Natürlich, was sonst? Was sonst? Dann add your own pro tip to the comments.
Natürlich, was sonst? Dann add your own pro tip to the comments.
Dann add your own pro tip to the comments.
Natürlich, was sonst? Dann add your own pro tip 25 pro tip 25 pro tip.
그럼 abonniere den Kanal.
Ich würde 없어際 charger noch immer nenne.
Northern
Moment, wo, das muss, das verwende ich zu...
Ich habe einen Pen, keine Ahnung, ich habe meins vor über einem Jahr gekauft.
Es gibt Nachfolger davon, es gibt Nachfolger-Bots davon, muss man gucken.
Ja.
Benutze ich auch viel zu wenig.
Es ist eigentlich richtig praktisch.
Ja, benutze ich auch nicht.
Ja.
Okay, dann ist Facebook zu 90% rot.
Also Facebook lädt ja mittlerweile, irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 30 MB JavaScript oder so, bevor die Seite überhaupt funktioniert.
Und wer es mir nicht glaubt, passt mal auf, ich zeige euch das, das stimmt.
Das ist richtig krass.
Facebook, soll man laden, ohne Cache?
Na gut, ich muss eingeloggt sein dafür.
Guck mal, jetzt haben wir nur...
Okay, ich brauche mal eine Facebook-Seite.
Wer hat eine Facebook-Seite?
Äh, ah, guck mal, ich.
Haha.
So, und jetzt das Ganze, und jetzt das Ganze ohne Cache.
Okay, 10 MB, sind nur 10 MB, 10 MB.
Die haben das aber schon hardcore optimiert.
Sind nur 10 MB.
Es ist weniger geworden.
Aber trotzdem ganz schön viel.
Ja.
Ja, das kenne ich.
Moment, das geht?
Wusste ich gar nicht, dass das funktioniert.
Ich dachte, das geht nur, wenn man JQuery verwendet.
Oh, das ist Select All.
Das wusste ich auch noch nicht.
Ich dachte, man muss dann sagen,
Dokument, Select, Query, bla bla bla bla.
Ja.
Ach.
Das ist immer, muss ich auch noch nicht.
Das wusste ich nicht.
Ich copy-paste immer unten in diese Command-Line rein.
Und Firefox erlaubt mir das neuerdings nicht.
Wo du sagst erstmal, bitte Paste-Enable machen.
Ich erlaube kein Copy-Paste.
Das ist tatsächlich richtig praktisch.
Moment, sehe ich das richtig?
Man kann Const-Variable neu deklarieren mit
Hä?
Okay.
JavaScript-Dinge.
Ach.
Das ist ja cool.
Da kann ich indirekt einen Selektor
äh, ähm
kopieren, der das Ding dann
später, äh, wo ich das dann später auswählen kann.
Ich hab die ganze Zeit dafür so einen
so einen Add-on verwendet.
Äh, für Chrome.
Dass die Tasten, der, dass die, dass die
Interaktion mit der Webseite aufzeichnen kann.
Aber das ist ja nice. Wusste gar nicht, dass das da dabei ist.
Wenn du einen Element in der DOM klickst,
wird es dir alle CSS-Styles zeigen,
die in den Styles-Tab angezeigt werden.
Aber was, wenn du die Styles sehen willst,
wenn ein Element aufgeführt oder fokussiert ist?
Du kannst das machen, wenn du einen Element aufklickst
oder von der Styles-Panel.
Das kenn ich.
Das, das kenn ich, das kenn ich.
Ja, der Typ macht echt gute Videos.
Von dem kannst du dir fast jedes einzelne Video geben.
Und jetzt, da...
What the fuck, was?
Was bin ich hier sehend?
Äh, CSS-Animation. Ne, das ist mir eh zu hoch.
CSS-Animation.
CSS-Animation krieg ich eh nicht gebacken.
Da bin ich zu low-brained für.
Ja, das ist ja auch super-awesome und all,
but the best kind of code is the code that you don't have to write.
If you're working with Flexbox or Gridlayout,
go to the Layout-Tab and draw visual markers
around those elements by checking the boxes
that you want to see.
Back in the Styles-Tab, if you go to the Display-Property
and install Flexbox or Grid,
you'll see an icon that you can click on.
Das ist tatsächlich sehr...
Jetzt wird's aber advanced.
Alter, was ist denn jetzt los?
Also ich find's ja schon cool, dass man das überhaupt angezeigt bekommen kann,
wo was aufhört.
Was zum...?
Was da alles eingebaut ist?
Das hab ich noch nie im Leben gesehen.
...for box shadows, which are notoriously difficult to code by hand.
What the fuck?
But if you'd rather modify your website
with something more like an actual design tool,
check out the Visbug-Extension.
It allows you to interact with the webpage itself
and modify its appearance without knowing
or understanding CSS whatsoever.
Was sich alles gibt.
Now, your design may look good on your machine,
but how do you know it's responsive to different screen sizes?
It provides a bunch of common screen sizes to choose from,
or you can use a responsive option
to resize it yourself manually.
And you can even throttle the network speed here
to simulate low-end devices.
But the fun doesn't stop there.
If you're targeting mobile devices...
Leider, leider hat dieser Mobile-Sachen
nichts mit dem zu tun, wie Safari die Sachen anzeigt,
weil Safari einfach nur der Sack ist.
...motion, you can simulate things like
GPS-Coordinates...
Du kannst da auch dein CSS zusammenklicken, doch.
...from the sensors panel.
Then you're likely building a progressive web app.
The Lighthouse tool will analyze your website
for performance, search engine optimization,
and progressive web app features.
If you pass the audit...
Aber Lighthouse haben sie doch letztens mal geflamed,
weil das irgendwas gemacht hat, was man nicht machen sollte.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was das war.
Ich weiß nur noch, dass Lighthouse übelstes
geflame abbekommen hat, mal vor einem Jahr oder so.
Ich weiß aber nicht mehr, warum...
...your website can be installed on a mobile device
just like a native app.
And if you fail the audit, it will tell you exactly
what you need to address in order to make the experience
for Google users better.
One of the most common issues is that a website is slow
to paint the initial content, and that's usually
because it tries to load too much JavaScript
and CSS. You can inspect exactly
how the browser loads all of your assets
Es waren noch Zeiten, wo du einfach auf eine Webseite
gegangen bist, und die Webseite ist
geladen und hat sie direkt angezeigt.
Heute lädt das erstmal 30 Milliarden
JavaScript-Sachen runter, und dann brauchst du
das JavaScript, um das HTML zu erzeugen,
was du siehst.
...it creates a waterfall graphic that shows every request
the browser makes and how long it takes
to fetch each one of those assets.
If you're worried about performance, turn on screenshots
to see how your website loads
after each request is completed.
If you're worried about performance, turn on screenshots
to see how your website loads after each request is completed.
Clicking on an individual item will provide a breakdown
of the response body and headers.
And if you want to dive really deep into performance,
click on the timing panel.
We'll show you exactly how long it took to fetch something,
breaking down the timing all the way to the DNS level.
What you didn't know, though, is that there's actually
a server timing API that allows you to pass
more detailed information from your server
to the browser.
When the server timing header is present on a response,
Chrome will automatically break that information down
in the browser dev tools.
For the end user, there are many issues when it comes to performance.
Response, animation, idle, and load.
Lighthouse and the network panel can help you debug
loading issues, but for the other three,
we'll need to analyze the actual runtime
performance of our code, which we can...
Ah, hier. Das ist Kokona-Style.
Erst mal Medikamente bei Amazon kaufen.
...in the performance panel. Hit the record button...
Die Amis haben ja auch ihre Schmerztabletten-Dinger.
Da haben die immer so einen
5000-Tabletten-Riesenkübel.
So nach dem Motto, ich brauch Schmerztabletten.
...using your site like an end user.
When you end the recording,
it'll give you a breakdown of the CPU usage,
frames per second,
and the amount of memory allocated to the heat.
If you notice a spike in CPU usage,
a drop in frames per second,
or a jump in memory usage,
it might indicate an area of code that needs to be optimized.
To investigate further,
Chrome has generated a flame chart
that breaks down everything that happens
on the browser's mainframe.
In other words, this is how the browser executes
your JavaScript step by step.
The x-axis represents time...
Ja, das war noch Zeiten, wo Webseiten
einfach HTML war.
Heute sieht eine Webseite so aus.
...the call stack.
If the chart is really tall, it's not much of a problem.
You might just be calling deeply nested functions.
But if a frame is really wide,
it means that something is taking a long time.
In which case, you should click on it
in more detail.
In some cases, the main thread might be fine,
but your code might create a memory leak
by allocating memory to objects that you no longer need.
You can tell you have a memory leak
Mein Code kreiert nie Memory Leaks.
Habt ihr schon jemals in meinem Stream gesehen,
dass ich irgendwo mal einen Memory Leak produziert habe?
Das kann überhaupt nicht sein.
But to investigate it further,
let's head over to the memory tab.
Select the option for allocation instrumentation,
then hit the record button.
Mein neues GIF-Tool.
Ich habe nicht ich das Memory Leak produziert,
sondern FFmpeg.
Kann ich da nichts für.
...that is still in use,
while the gray bars indicate memory that was garbage collected.
At any point in time, you can see every object
that's currently allocated to the heap.
It can be sorted by size,
allowing you to figure out exactly which objects
are clogging up your memory.
Okay, das ist mir jetzt zu big brain.
Das ist jetzt zu...
But here's one more bonus tip to leave you with.
If you like Chrome DevTools,
then you'll also like Brave Browser.
Brave Browser is a browser that I use for most of my personal work.
It's based on Chromium,
so all of the DevTools are exactly the same.
And the CEO of the company is none other than
Brendan Eich, the inventor of Javascript.
But most importantly,
it's privacy-focused with built-in
ad-blocking capabilities.
Gut, das ist Werbung, der muss gucken,
dass er Geld verdient.
So Leute, jetzt. Bam.
Eine Runde Battlefield Top Plays.
Das muss jetzt einfach noch sein.
Das muss ich mir jetzt noch geben.
11 Minuten Battlefield Top Plays.
Nee, wir gucken uns jetzt nicht die Lavalampen an.
Wobei, die gehen nur 3 Minuten,
das können wir gucken.
Chat, Chat, was ist los mit den Lavalampen?
Warum sollen wir uns die Lavalampen angucken?
Das stimmt.
Random Number Generator
sind in der Regel nicht sonderlich random.
Zumindest wenn man den Seed kennt.
Denn alle modernen Encryptionen,
insbesondere der Padlock auf deinem Browser,
der dir sagt, dass du sicher bist,
alles hängt an den richtigen randomen Nummern.
Wenn du diese Nummern irgendwie präsentieren kannst,
kannst du diese Locks starten.
Deswegen bin ich hier,
an der Hauptstelle von Cloudflare in San Francisco.
Cloudflare ist ein Service,
das Websites und Web-Services schützt
und sich vor dem Maserati befindet.
Was haben die denn für komischen Sound?
Etwa 10% der Web-Sendungen
fliegt durch den Maserati.
Ja.
Der Breistamp geht auch durch Cloudflare.
In short,
these folks deal with a lot of encrypted internet traffic,
so they need lots of random numbers.
Let's Encrypt.
It is possible to write code
that will simulate randomness
and that's good enough for a lot of uses.
But in theory, those numbers could be predicted
Die wollen uns nicht wirklich erzählen, dass Cloudflare den Random Number aus Lavalampen füttert, oder?
Warum nimmt man da nicht irgendwelche Partikel in der Atmosphäre oder sowas?
Irgendwelches Rauschen?
Wirklich?
Ich meine, die Idee ist schon richtig cool.
Das ist eigentlich eine richtig geile Idee.
Eigentlich eine coole Idee.
Okay, aber die nehmen das auch nicht für jede Random Number.
Die nehmen das als Seed.
Also sprich, die nehmen schon einen schnellen Pseudo-Random-Generator, aber die seeden das mit einem echten Random.
Das ist natürlich eine coole Idee, das mit so zu machen.
Ja, genau.
Einfach die Pixel nehmen und irgendwie SHA-256, was auch immer, draus machen.
Ja, das ist eine richtig coole Idee.
So, we use that to help scatter the randomness as much as possible.
We also collect randomness around the world.
Das macht Random Org auch.
Ich dachte, Random Org macht irgendwelche atmosphärischen, äh, irgendwelches Rauschen, frag mich nicht.
Ich wusste nicht, dass Random Org das mit Lavalampen macht.
Genau, Radioempfänger.
Genau, genau.
Irgendwelches Rauschen in der Atmosphäre oder so macht Random Org.
In our office we have this thing called a chaotic pendulum.
It has three pieces and it's unpredictable in which way they kind of...
twist and turn together.
We videotape that and feed it into our...
Das ist eine richtig coole Idee.
In our Singapore office we have a radioactive source that we use to...
Oh, radioaktiv.
So, this is not just some stunt that we pulled.
It's actually, you know, being fed into our real systems.
Whether anything in the world is truly random is arguably a question of philosophy and not science.
Maybe everything is just complicated clockwork.
But these lava lamps are so chaotic that simulating that camera shot with perfect pixel accuracy...
is far enough ahead to be useful while figuring out everything else those images are being put through.
It's roughly the same level of difficulty as just brute forcing the encryption in the first place.
And even if you could simulate all that, you'd only have one piece of the puzzle.
These folks aren't the first to do this.
LavaRand was patented by a company called Silicon Graphics in 1996.
Ich finde, die ist cool.
But that only lasted a couple of years.
Now, of course, there are less flashy and more practical ways to generate random numbers.
But then I wouldn't be here.
I would be at some other company who'd gone and...
I don't know, pointed a camera at a basket of kittens.
That'd be a bit higher maintenance, though.
Aber das ist natürlich richtig geil.
Das ist komplette Randomness.
Was hat so eine LavaLampe?
100 Watt pro Lava...
Kein Schimmer.
Weiß ich nicht.
So, jetzt Runde Battlefield 3.
Pockers.
Er wieder.
Natürlich Metro M16.
Oh!
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Das gibt huge, huge Bash jetzt.
Sag mal, sind die...
Sag mal, seid ihr komplett BrainAFK oder was?
Was ist mit euch los?
Pepega-Gegner, ey.
Das sind...
Das waren die Tests für die Battlefield 2042 Bots.
Die haben in Wirklichkeit gerade den Bot-Code getestet für das nächste Battlefield.
Der Amtrak war auch so ein OP-Ding.
Leider, leider hast du einen gebraucht, der sich aufopfert und fährt.
Nice Heli-Snipes.
Oh, Doppel-Heli-Snipes.
Collateral-Heli-Snipes.
Und jetzt Heli-Klauen.
Pockers.
So muss das sein.
Weiß man schon was über SPMM und Battlefield 2042?
Ja, man weiß, dass sie...
Man weiß, dass man nix weiß.
Das einzige, was vermutet wird, wo sie, glaube ich, auch was zu gesagt haben, ist, dass
die kein übergreifendes, also Skill-Based-Matchmaking machen, sondern wenn du in den Server joinst,
werden quasi sowas wie Auto-Balancing passieren.
Anhand deiner globalen Stats.
Das heißt, dass Server-Matchmaking, also wenn du in den Server joinst, werden quasi
sowas wie Auto-Balancing passieren.
Anhand deiner globalen Stats.
Das heißt, dass Server-Matchmaking, also wenn du in den Server joinst, werden quasi
sowas wie Auto-Balancing passieren.
Anhand deiner globalen Stats.
Das heißt, dass Server-Matchmaking, also wenn du in den Server joinst, werden quasi
sowas wie Auto-Balancing passieren.
Anhand deiner globalen Stats.
Das heißt, dass Server selbst wird etwas besser balanced.
Mal gucken, wie krass das am Ende ausfallen wird.
Es ist ein bisschen wie die Auto-Balancer, die es jetzt schon gibt, die halt am Ende
eine Runde gucken, wer hat die meisten Punkte und sortiert das dann so, dass es im Durchschnitt
wieder stimmt.
Redet er heute gar nicht?
Das wäre mir sogar fast lieber.
Predicted. Predicted.
Ganz klar, dass da jetzt ein Chat reinfliegt. Predicted.
Natürlich, was sonst?
Calculated. Calculated.
Von Anfang an.
What?
Okay, das war äußerst glücklich.
Oh, da stehen sie.
Lass sie sich spreien.
Alter, lass sie sich wegspreien.
Die haben sich hart wegspreien lassen gerade.
Okay, da trifft
ein Heli jetzt.
Oh, da fliegt ein Jet rein oder sowas.
Bam.
Ne, nice.
Und noch den Hitchhiker.
Jawoll. Oh, ne.
Ich dachte, er trifft den Jet noch.
Ja.
Ich krieg die Dinger auch.
Die halten...
Generell equipt man den Battlefield 3-Held
unglaublich viel aus.
Oder ist schwer zu hitten.
Und der hittet jetzt.
Boah. Calculated. Ganz klar.
Ist klar.
Der hat aber gut gepasst dazu.
Genau.
wann der am besten anlagen kann.
Zag.
Ihr Roleplay war rausgegangen.
Ich wollte gerade sagen,
wie hat es der Typ geschafft,
ihn nicht zu killen von hinten.
Ah, er wieder.
Er wieder.
Jetzt kommen wieder irgendwelche Metro-Smokes.
Oh, da stehen sie, Alter.
Oh, die lassen sich so wegklatschen.
Craig's best.
Yeah, let's go.
Jawoll.
Bam.
G-16 No Scope.
Okay, so hat die Waffe kaum einer gespielt.
Oh, wie sie es nicht checken.
Alter, wie sie es nicht checken.
Wie sie es nicht kapieren.
Lull.
Richtige Lowbrain, Leute.
Boah.
Also eins muss man sagen, die G-18, das ist echt mega OP in dem Game.
Aber ich spiele trotzdem lieber Rex.
Rex, Beste.
Ja, kommt halt vor.
Kennst du den Rex-Song, ne?
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Jetzt sitzen sie wieder am Arsch der Welt rum und snipen.
Der Typ wieder.
Der macht doch nichts anderes.
Wir sind den ganzen Tag dort auf dieser, von dem haben wir schon 50 Clips gesehen,
die gleiche Posi auf der gleichen Map.
Der macht echt sein Leben lang nichts anderes, als auf der einen Posi zu stehen
und in die eine Richtung zu snipen.
Oh, nice, doppelt.
Triple.
Hitmarker.
Nee.
Nice.
Also das sind Sniping-Clips, damit kann ich nichts anfangen.
Ganz ehrlich, so cool die Dinger sind, aber das sind meistens Sniper, die null zur Runde beitragen.
Es ist ja ganz cool, wenn du Firestorm oder Caspian Border oder sonst wie 20 Minuten rumstehst und zwei Kills machst,
aber das bringt halt gar nichts.
Das ist komplett useless, diese paar Kills, die die Leute dann machen, die Runde.
Dann sind wir Leute, die aktiv...
Ich sag euch, je nachdem, wie gut das wird mit Gadgets ausrüsten und jeder kann sich heilen und sonst wie was,
die ganzen Schneiber, ey, die ganzen Rumlieger, Noscoper und, nee, Hardscoper,
die werden, das wird die Pest in Battlefield 20.
42, wenn da nicht irgendwas kommt, was da das einschränkt.
Das sind dann 80% Sniper, die Runde.
Und du kannst noch nicht mal Sniper-Limit machen, außer du baust dein Portal selbst was zusammen.
Ey, das ist doch gestellt, oder?
Das ist doch gestellt.
Das kann mir doch keiner erzählen, dass der Typ da so random einfach nur immer gegenüber rumschwebt.
Warum sollte der das denn machen?
Außer er will gesniped werden.
Check out this clip from an intense close quarters streak.
It's a bit of a rampage from killed in action, getting behind the enemy players as they're all pinned up against this wall.
Oh, wie sie sich wegsprayen lassen.
Erstmal in Smoke rein, jawohl.
Okay.
Der schießt einfach immer auf die gleiche Stelle und die Leute rennen weiterhin raus.
WTF? Alter!
Alter!
Das ist wieder Bot-Simulation für Battlefield 20. 42.
WTF?
Ah, der Smoke.
Der Smoke.
Das ist das Beste.
Das ist geil, wenn er seine Smoke-Launcher-Kills macht.
Direct-Impact-Smokes.
Und die checken es wieder nicht.
Los!
Da ist er.
Oh nein!
Ausgerechnet...
Die Gegner!
Null!
Oh!
I hit him!
Die Gegner!
Okay, die hat er schön weggestanden.
Alter!
Pepega-Camper-Gegner!
Wie sie es nicht checken!
Alter!
Wie low-brain!
Wie low-brain kann man sein?
WTF?
Ultra low-brain!
Ich hab nicht inтобo!
Ich hab den
Schildesprung!
Und wie bin ich zu den Einen verwundert?
Zwischenm 천.
Richtig.
Du wirst dich nicht wagen lassen.
Wetten Sie was ich sage.
Als er mich über ihn aufhörte.
Ich bin einfach zu hoch gekommen.
Ich bin nicht vertreten geworden.
Ich muss mich an den Einen verlassen.
Ich bin nur ein kleiner Schlau-Train-Wיי.
Ich bin ein Einer für Sie.
Und ich bin ein Einer für Sie.
Ich bin ein Einer für euch.
und Spawn-Immunity klitschen.
Guck, der bewegt sich zu früh.
Den Fehler habe ich auch lange gemacht.
Einfach nichts machen.
Dann bist du Spawn-Immune.
Na klar.
Gunmaster war pock.
Das Einzige, was ich ein bisschen doof fand,
das forcierte Wechsel der Waffen in Gunmaster.
Ich hätte es besser gefunden.
Man muss einen Knopf drücken zum Switchen.
Weil manchmal war es sehr unglücklich,
wie er die Waffe geswitcht hat nach einem Kill.
Sie könnten ja auch sagen, der Kill zählt dann nicht,
wenn man nicht switcht.
Gaben!
Der echte.
Der Trick ist sofort auf,
schon wieder.
Ach, war das so?
Ja.
Der Klassiker.
Gaben zockt Battlefield 3, ja.
Sau rein, das soll lieber Half-Life 3 machen.
Sehr gut.
Logitech!
Bam!
Leute.
Ich habe Hunger.
Ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Ist da Frasier am Start?
Chat?
Ne.
Ist da Frasier da?
Zeig mal her.
Ja.
Nein.
War schon ewig nicht mehr on.
So, kann nicht jemand hosten?
Zeig mal kurz hier gucken.
Nope.
Keiner da.
Heute Abend wieder Hetzner.
Ich bin mir noch nicht ganz sicher.
Ich muss das noch ein bisschen vorbereiten.
Und ich glaube, ich habe noch nicht genug dafür gemacht.
Und ich muss noch das Stellenanzeigen-Video fertig aufnehmen.
Leute, ich gehe jetzt.
Ich muss aufs Klo.
Und den Hunger habe ich auch.
Keine Kombination, mit der man noch lange streamen kann.
Also Leute, wir sehen uns bis dann.
See you.
Outro